essence considérablement majoré par la
situation économique culturel social
familial qui lie au japon quand on boit
une bouteille de champagne ont fait le
même geste que la reine d'angleterre ou
car grands milliardaires c'est une
cérémonie du champagne c'est beaucoup
plus qu'un vin c'est un mythe construit
depuis 250 ans qui veut dire la fête
l'amour la célébration la générosité
il ya beaucoup qui vont pouvoir
fabriquer du champagne ah non non parce
que non non le champagne tient une
grande partie de son succès d'un terroir
particulier celle va justement de la
négociation de la diplomatie c'est le
vin de oui oui qui abolit les frontières
c'est pour ça que moi je ne mets pas de
nationalisme dans champagne sous la tour
eiffel le champagne c'est en effet le
chat des passes à des passe quelque part
la france maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau et nos reporters sur
le terrain voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 13 janvier
l'issue diplomatique est elle encore
possible en libye c'est en tout cas ce à
quoi s'attelle moscou sergueï lavrov a
reçu aujourd'hui les deux rivaux libyen
un rallye faf tard est fayez el harrach
ce dernier chef du gouvernement reconnu
par l'onu a signé un document
concrétisant le feu le cessez-le-feu
d'hyères le premier lui prend le temps
d'y réfléchir rappelons que ce cessez le
feu doit servir de prélude à une
conférence internationale sur la libye
le 19 janvier prochain
[Musique]
le gouvernement iranien nie avoir tenté
de masquer la responsabilité des
autorités dans le crash de l'avion de
ligne l'ukrainien battu par erreur près
de téhéran le 8 janvier
un drame qui suscite la colère dans le
pays où des manifestations anti
gouvernementales ont lieu en france le
retrait provisoire de la chp pivot comme
annoncé par le premier ministre edouard
philippe n'aura pas convaincu les
syndicalistes les plus déterminés qui
poursuivent leur mouvement
les avocats aussi vent debout contre
cette réforme ont été reçus par la
ministre de la justice qui s'est engagé
à répondre dans les plus brefs délais à
leurs préoccupations
[Musique]
resserrer le front djihadistes emmanuel
macron réuni les présidents de cinq pays
du sahel à pau alors que les attaques se
multiplient le niger a subi jeudi
dernier la pire attaque de son histoire
avec 89 soldats tués quels sont les
enjeux de cette rencontre la
stabilisation politique économique dans
la région est-elle mission impossible
la france doit-elle rester engagés sur
place ce sera l'objet de notre face à
face à 21h30
[Musique]
des progrès ont donc été notées sur la
crise en libye selon le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov a
reçu aujourd'hui à moscou le chef du
gouvernement libyen reconnu par l'onu
fayez al azhar a chez son rival rallye
faf tard l'homme fort de l'est libyen
fayez al azhar h qui refuse de
rencontrer physiquement son rival a
signé un accord sur les modalités du
cessez-le-feu entré en vigueur hier un
cessez le feu qui intervient alors que
la turquie a déployé des hommes on
soutient ce dernier plus de précision
avec antoine claireaux après plus de six
heures de pourparlers le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
accompagné de son homologue turc mevlüt
çavusoglu se sont présentés face à la
presse est très rapidement sans répondre
à aucune question ils ont fait état de
discussions très intense parfois tendues
entre toutes les parties présentes les
deux ministres ont déclaré que malgré
tout il était parvenu à la rédaction
d'un document final qui qui décrit les
contours de ce cessez-le-feu un document
signé par fayez elle sa rage le chef du
gouvernement d'union national libyen
mais pas par khalifa haftar l'homme fort
de l'est libyen je vous propose
d'écouter la déclaration du ministre
russe des affaires étrangères
quand j'arrivais dans mes gosses pas bah
oui mesdames et messieurs nous tenons à
vous informer des progrès à temps à
l'heure actuelle aujourd'hui dès le
matin des consultations intenses avec
des parties libyennes et avec le soutien
des ministres turcs et russes des
affaires étrangères et de la défense a
été examiné un document qui permettra de
concrétiser les questions liées au
régime de cessez le feu
comme nos amis libyens nous l'ont dit
ils ont demandé un délai jusqu'à demain
matin et demain matin si le général
akhtar signe ce document comme suite de
l'initiative proposée par les deux
présidents
outin hier doan nous obtiendrons que sa
rage et à
stars prennent des engagements
nécessaires cessez-le-feu se poursuivra
et nous lançons le processus politique
dans le cadre des efforts de la
communauté internationale et de l'onu
ici run et même aux hommes de roy
hodgson après des années progresse de
style notes et les radios s'arrachent le
maréchalat stark au monde on de l'armée
nationale libyenne et monsieur aguilar
salah le représentant de la chambre des
élus de tobrouk
je donne une appréciation positive de ce
document et ont demandé d'avoir un peu
de ton supplémentaire jusqu'à demain
matin pour prendre une décision finale
quant à la signature de ce document
j'espère que cette décision sera
positive
les représentants turcs et russes
continueront à aider les parties à
mettre en oeuvre les accords qui
constitue l'objectif
les pourparlers actuels
quant au look c'est cher et d'autre les
gars
les deux ministres ont souligné que si
elle parvenait à signer ce document
alors ce pourrait être le début de la
relance du processus politique en libye
quoi qu'il en soit le prochain rendez
vous d'importance et maintenant dimanche
prochain le 19 janvier à berlin avec la
conférence internationale convoquée par
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
entre temps la situation sur le terrain
et le respect du cessez-le-feu sera
observé de très près cessez-le-feu qu
emmanuel macron veut crédible durable et
vérifiable on le rappelle le pays est
dans une situation très précaire depuis
la chute de mouammar kadhafi
florian lambert l'appel au cessez le feu
finalement entendus par les deux parties
le chef du gène annoncé ce dimanche
qu'il acceptait la trêve
fayez est la rage a toutefois prévenu
qu'il se réservait le droit de riposter
en cas d'attaqué de l'autre camp
auparavant son rival de l'armée
nationale libyenne la haine elle avait
lui aussi répondu favorablement à
l'appel à la trêve lancé mercredi
par ankara et moscou le porte-parole de
l'aena commandé par khalifa haftar on a
fait l'annoncé à la télévision
le commandement général des forces
armées arabe libyenne annoncent un
cessez le feu des opérations militaires
dans la région de l'ouest effective à
partir de minuit le 12 janvier 2020 nous
demandons à la partie adverse de mettre
en oeuvre ce cessez le feu à la même
heure la riposte sera sévère en cas de
violation de la trêve dans le camp
adverse une suspension des combats alors
que khalifa haftar a lancé une offensive
sur tripoli depuis le mois d'avril ce
répit intervient après un intense ballet
diplomatique cette semaine conduits
notamment par la turquie et la russie
les deux pays se sont imposés ces
dernières semaines comme des acteurs
clés en libye ankara ainsi déployer des
militaires en janvier pour soutenir le
gène à de fayyad et la rage de son côté
la russie soutiendrait les troupes de
khalifa haftar le conflit en libye était
justement au coeur des discussions ce
samedi lors d'une rencontre entre la
chancelière allemande et le président
russe nous avons surtout discuter de la
libye où malheureusement les actions
militaires à grande échelle se
poursuivent et où les activités
terroristes se développe alors que les
secteurs économique et social se
détériore au détriment de tous cela mine
la stabilité dans la région mais a aussi
une influence négative sur le rapport de
son côté angela merkel redoutent que le
pays devienne une seconde syrie une
conférence sur la libye se tiendra le 19
janvier prochain sous l'égide des
nations unies à berlin
objectif donner une chance aux parties
libyennes de rétablir la paix dans le
pays
la libye également au menu d'une réunion
entre le président turc recep tayyip
erdogan et le premier ministre italien
giuseppe compte et ankara aujourd'hui
est les deux hommes appellent un cessez
le feu durable et ont souligné
l'importance de mettre fin à l'escaladé
de violence sur le terrain q monsieur de
moscou dehors
nous avons reçu de nos amis des signes
d'un bon résultat à l'issue de la
réunion de moscou
si dieu le veut à partir de là j'ai avec
ses résultats mais durant texte et nous
irons à berlin avec son flegme dieu le
veut avec le travail à berlin
nous organisons ce cessez le feu sur des
bases solides
inch'allah bourriche es salaam examinait
autres couches aux gens ce thème animaux
de l'udc est beau mon souhait est qu'un
cessez le feu est une base solide soit
la base de la paix pour l'avenir de nos
frères et soeurs libyens de nos amis
libyens libèrent de jim bilba du mln et
toulouges et pour en parler nous sommes
avec claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir toques
blanches saison merci d'être avec nous
alors tout d'abord pour but bien qu'on
comprenne la libye pourquoi est ce si
important
c'est très important pour la sécurité de
l'europe et cela pour trois raisons la
première raison c'est que la libye a des
frontières communes avec la tunisie pays
fragiles quand on connaît bien
l'algérie pays sensible qu'on connaît
bien aussi et puis avec deux pays du
sahel
deux des cinq pays qui sur lesquels
opère la force barkan dont les chefs
d'état sont d'ailleurs aujourd'hui à pau
avec le président la république
française pour décider de l'évolution
l'intervention la force markale qui est
là pour aider les armées des pays en
question à lutter contre le terrorisme
islamique
donc la libye
jouxte tous ces pays est au centre de
l'action en deuxième lieu la libye est
le pays par lequel passe un certain
nombre de migrants qui viennent du sahel
et qui sont d'ailleurs assez souvent
retenus dans des camps en libye et qui
cherche à retrouver des passeurs dans
les différents ports de libye qui
moyennant finances
les envoie sur des barques et
malheureusement très souvent les envoie
à la mort sur la mer méditerranée
et puis en troisième lieu la libye fait
un pays qui a beaucoup de ressources en
hydrocarbures et par conséquent
évidemment les grandes puissances
regarde de très près ce qui se passe en
libye
pour cette troisième raison également
donc c'est très important et c'est très
important que on arrive à stabiliser la
libye
pour ces trois raisons alors un cessez
le feu en serait la première mesure de
désescalade entreprises depuis 2010 9
peut-on la tribu l influence de la
médiation turco russe oui bien sûr alors
c'est assez logique puisque la russie a
de bons contacts a gardé de bons
contacts avec le gouvernement a reconnu
par l'onu
ce sa rage a trait à tripoli mais
qu'elle a aussi des contacts encore plus
intense avec le match à la star et que
par conséquent elle est considérée comme
pouvant modéré le maréchal a fait appel
à des moyens de pression suffisamment
important pour eelv et imposer un cessez
le feu
on voit bien que c'est ce qui s'est
passé puisque pour sa part monsieur sa
rage à tripoli se sentait menacée
n'ayant plus tellement le choix il est
allé demander le secours de la turquie
et la turquie lui a répondu
nous allons vous aider avec une aide
militaire
iliad militaire un peu particulière
d'ailleurs parce que ce sont des troupes
d'obédience turcs mais qui viennent de
syrie qui viennent de syrie
donc ça complique encore un peu le
schéma pas ce que ça veut dire que il ya
aujourd'hui en libye des troupes
étrangères
sans doute syrienne du rck est pas
officiellement russe mais les
observateurs ont depuis quelques temps
indiqué qu'il y avait sans doute des
milices privées de type wagner est ce
que par conséquent on peut dire que la
turquie et la russie se sont les grands
gagnants au niveau diplomatique sans
doute mais ça n'est que la première
étape
alors d'abord il faut il faut que le
maréchal haftar qui a demandé un délai
de réflexion jusqu'à demain matin si le
document sur le cessez le feu
ensuite ce cessez le feu il va falloir
l'appliquer et il est vrai aussi que le
représentant spécial de l'onu pour la
libye
monsieur salamé a déclaré aujourd'hui
même qu' il fallait sans doute des
observateurs peut-être même des trous
peut-être même des casques bleus enfin
on ne sait pas pour s'assurer que le
cessez le feu est totalement respectée
et puis ensuite le débouché ce sera la
conférence de berlin que la chancelière
merkel a convoqué pour le week-end
prochain avec l'accord du président
poutine puisqu'elle rencontrait le
président poutine à la fin de la semaine
dernière une conférence qui aura
plusieurs volets comme toutes les
conférences de l'onu
un volet sécuritaire le sait ses voeux
un volet politique le partage du pouvoir
probablement ce qui est plus difficile
comment est ce que le maréchal haftar va
rentrer dans le système de pouvoir qui
existent d'ores et déjà à tripoli sous
l'égide de l'onu et puis troisième
volets le volet développement économique
et c'est là peut-être que l'union
européenne pourra apporter sa
contribution alors la france elle ou se
situe-t-elle de manière plus générale
également les européens dans cette
affaire bah les européens sont exprimés
le président de la république française
a dit qu'il voulait que cessez le feu
soit cessez le feu durable est
susceptible d'être contrôlé bon ça c'est
là pour la première étape pour le reste
il est clair que dans le passé il avait
déjà essayé de faire que monsieur sa
rage et le match à la star se
rencontrent ils étaient rencontrés
d'ailleurs à côté de paris
mais ce n'était pas encore mûr ce
n'était pas encore la bonne occasion je
crois aussi que les européens en tant
que tel ont des intérêts majeurs la
preuve le premier ministre le président
du conseil italien et à être en turquie
aujourd'hui pour discuter avec monsieur
erdogan est évidemment il ya derrière
tout ça aussi les intérêts pétroliers
qui ne sont pas étrangers d'ailleurs à
l'empressement de la turquie pour voler
au secours du gouvernement de tripoli
mais bien sûr les nids la grande
entreprise nationale italienne est
installé en libye depuis très longtemps
elle a des actifs et elle fait de la
recherche pétrolière et gazière
pétrolière depuis très longtemps et bien
entendu total est aussi actif dans ce
domaine
alors on le sait le dossier est épineux
avec ses forces antagonistes
comment trouver un compromis qui veut
quoi la difficulté ça va être le partage
du pouvoir comme je le signalais tout à
l'heure je pense que la conférence de
berlin qui sera une conférence étoffé
organisée sous l'égide de l'organisation
des nations unies mais évidemment en
présence des européens le pays hôte
l'allemagne mais aussi les principaux
pays européens
monsieur borel qui est leur représentant
pour la politique étrangère et la
sécurité en europe le nouveau
représentant
il y aura certainement lui aussi des
propositions à faire notamment sur le
troisième volet la difficulté ça va être
pour l'onu de mettre en place un
dispositif qui assure le maintien du
cessez le feu et ensuite en effet de
convaincre le maréchal haftar qui n'est
pas né de la dernière pluie
c'est quelqu'un qui a une grande
expérience il n'est pas tout jeune il a
78 temps de s'entendre avec le premier
ministre de tripoli qui lui à peine 60
ans donc il ya peut-être un petit
problème de génération mais cela dit il
faut en effet qu'ils trouvent le moyen
de s'entendre et de et le partager le
pouvoir
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france
deux jours après avoir reconnu sa
culpabilité dans le crash du boeing 737
d'ukrainiens airlines le gouvernement
iranien nie aujourd'hui avoir tenté
d'étouffer la faire une déclaration
réponse aux manifestations
antigouvernementales qui ont éclaté ce
week-end un peu partout dans le pays
une pression de la rue donc mais aussi
international le premier ministre du
canada demandent des réponses de son
côté l'émir du qatar en visite à téhéran
tente d'apaiser les tensions au sujet de
françois xavier lambert rémédier ski fis
l'émir du qatar revêt ses habits de
médiateur alors que doit entretient de
bonnes relations avec l'iran
tamim al-thani a rencontré le président
iranien et le guide suprême
l'occasion pour l'émir d'exhorter les
différents acteurs à un apaisement des
tensions
hassan rohani s'est de son côté montré
plus mesuré que lors de ses dernières
déclarations à l'encontre des états unis
en raison de l'importance que nous
accordons à la sécurité régionale en
particulier concernant les voies
navigables du golfe persique et le
détroit d'ormuz et de la mer dauman nous
avons décidé de mener davantage
négociations et de confrontation pour la
sécurité de l'ensemble de cette visite
intervient à montrer critique dans la
région
nous avons convenu avec mon frère et
avec son excellence le président en
compagnie de la seule solution à ces
crises résidents la désescalade dialogue
est la seule solution à ces crimes de
son côté le porte parole du gouvernement
iranien ali rabier a tenu ce lundi à
prévenir les états unis des iraniens ont
bien l'intention de ne pas céder face à
leur rival américain inc est égale les
américains donnent des messages qui
n'ont rien à voir avec les autres et
veulent nous parler directement
nous n'avons pas confiance en eux
s'ils lèvent les sanctions et supprime
la pression sur notre peuple fait chez
nous parlerons mais chez moi me prenne
ses choix comme en boucle nous pensons
que ce single or ces vins du terrain et
intensifierons encore plus leur pression
malheureusement nous n'avons pas été en
mesure d'expliquer clairement aux gens
pourquoi nous résistons états unis
donald trump n'est pas digne de
confiance
ils pensent qu'en mettant les gens
ordinaires sous pression il obtenir ce
qu'il veut il nous forcer à battre en
retraite
je poserai les ténors tt games et malgré
des discours diplomatique plus aisés la
population iranienne continue de
manifester dans les rues de téhéran des
dizaines de personnes se sont ainsi
réunis devant l'ambassade du royaume uni
au lendemain de la brève arrestation de
l'ambassadeur britannique
ce dernier avait été accusée d'avoir
pris part à un rassemblement à la
mémoire des victimes
un hommage jugées illégales par téhéran
il s'agit d'une manifestation contre
l'ingérence dans les affaires des autres
et à la tête de la base aérienne
américaine constitue un petit dur pour
eux nos amis profitent généralement des
troubles internes pour se venger et
tromper l'opinion publique et ses
manifestations contre les dirigeants
iraniens ont continué pour leur demander
de rendre des comptes après la
destruction du boeing d'ukrainiens
airlines la presse locale n'a d'ailleurs
pas ménagé le pouvoir qualifiant la
destruction de l'avion d'actes
impardonnable les tensions restent
également forte sur le plan militaire
cinq jours après deux premières frappes
iranienne sur des bases en irak
plusieurs roquettes d'origine
indéterminée aurait à nouveau visé un
camp abritant des soldats américains
indigné par les informations sur une
nouvelle attaque à la roquette contre
une base aérienne irakienne
je prie pour un prompt rétablissement
des blessés et j'exhorte le gouvernement
d'irak à tenir responsables ceux qui
sont derrière cette attaque contre le
peuple irakien
loin de cette démonstration de force
toronto rendait hommage aux 57 victimes
canadiennes de l'accident
près de 2000 personnes se sont réunies
pour une cérémonie commémorative
très ému le premier ministre canadien a
promis aux familles des victimes que
justice sera rendue
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
patrick forestier écrivain spécialiste
du moyen-orient hauteur de hôtel
palestine chronique inattendue de la
guerre en irak aux éditions grasset
bonsoir patrick forestier merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
gouvernement iranien qui nie à
aujourd'hui avoir tenté de masquer la
responsabilité de l'iran dans ce drame
dans ce crash de l'avion ça vous paraît
crédible
les faits parlent d'eux mêmes c'est à
dire qu'il ya eu 48 heures où il ya eu
un flottement à la tête du pouvoir
iranien où les déclarations étaient
contradictoires
les responsables étaient gênés il ya
même eu des déclarations assez
péremptoire du du directeur de
l'aviation civile qui disait que c'était
pas que c'était impossible que le
missile soit tiré donc voilà quarante
huit heures après le pouvoir a dit la
vérité c'était il n'avait pas le choix
c'était de lemieux tu dois dire que mes
affaires parce que tout le monde à
l'étranger et à l'intérieur du pays
avait compris que c'était un missile
iranien qui avait donc toucher l'avion
ukrainien finalement qu'est ce qu'il
reproche le plus les manifestants à leur
gouvernement d'avoir caché la vérité
d'avoir commis cet horrible erreur c'est
quoi le vrai problème le vrai problème
je crois que d'abord c'est vrai que le
mensonge je ne passe pas des sociétés
toumani reds internet de communication
voilà qu'il existe également à
évidemment en iran où les jeunes sont
connectés sur internet
donc ça ça ne passe pas du tout et
d'autant plus que
les 57 donc iraniens qui sont morts dans
cet accident sont des jeunes soient des
jeunes étudiants qui allait donc étudié
à au canada donc si vous voulez dans les
universités et des familles évidemment
les copains sont très concernés par cet
accident et sont donc très remonté
contre le pouvoir qui est un problème
quand même avec la jeunesse
donc c'est mouillé tout se mélange et
c'est quand même une situation difficile
pour le régime iranien aujourd'hui
oui parce qu'il faut le dire l'iran il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes en
errance un pays où la moyenne d'âge et
est peu élevé est ce que ça peut être un
tournant pour justement le gouvernement
iranien on avait salué cette en tout cas
il avait salué l'unité retrouvée après
la mort du général souleymane sy une
unité qui à nouveau fragilisée ça peut
représenter un tournant
oui je pense parce que il ya eu
peut-être une unité derrière les
obsèques du général sur les manies mais
c'était pas du tout les mêmes le profil
si vous voulez mais bon c'était le voyez
sur les images il y avait des jeunes
évidemment parce qu'ils étaient
extrêmement nombreux mais c'était quand
même pas des étudiants ou des dés
des jeunes qui se passe je vais dire
engagé politiquement
là on a des jeunes qui sont voilà qui
veulent vivre comme le reste de la
planète
ils veulent internet vie et les filles
ont un problème avec avec le voile voilà
ce sont des choses que l'on connaît soit
des plus des phénomènes de société
ils sont tous patriotes ils aiment leur
pays et l'iran
il n'y a pas de problème là-dessus mais
ils veulent accéder à ce que tous les
jeunes de la planète accède à dire
société de consommation et là ça se
recouvrent si vous lisez ce il ya les
deux problématiques qui s'entrechoquent
et ça ça peut être assez explosif
justement c'était ma prochaine question
est ce que cette dramatique accident
peut mettre justement le feu aux poudres
à une révolte plus profonde et très
délicate
maintenant parce que les jeunes
étudiants dans les universités qui sont
déjà dans la rue et ce ne soit pas les
parents les familles qui vont les qui
vont aller contre leur enfant si vous
voulez donc c'est sur des problématiques
délicate et on voit on a vu aujourd'hui
pas simple le chef de la police de
téhéran qui a affirmé que donc ils
avaient reçu des ordres à ses strictes
pour ne pas
agir contre manifestation de manière
violente bien on a vu aussi des vidéos
où il eu des tirs
déjà sur surchauffe des manifestants
gouvernement allemand d'ailleurs aussi
un qui demande que ces manifestations se
déroulent sans entrave est ce qu'on peut
les craindre justement cette escalade
cette répression on peut le craindre
oui on peut la crainte de 6,6 et un
livre plus en avant on a vu comment
novembre il y eut
black-out total de l'iran qui a qui
avait fermé internet et qui s'était
replié sur lui même et qui a eu une
impression assez sanglante mais
plusieurs centaines de morts là depuis
il y avait les obsèques de mme annick
avait vu quand même l'esprit c'était
qu'il fallait se souder autour d'eux
autour de cet homme qui était présenté
comme comme étant un grand serviteur de
l'iran mais là je me dis c'est au nez
des monnaies or politiques soulevés sa
part de sa part de l'accident donc c'est
pas politique mais quand même commis par
par des des gardiens de la révolution
qui sont pas forcément très aimé par les
jeunes
alors est-ce que ce coup du sort c'est
je puis m'exprimer ainsi ne va pas
finalement servir les affaires de donald
trump qui pourtant elle a été sortie
unilatéralement de l'accord qui a voilà
fait éliminer ce général symbolique 1 en
iran et finalement voilà
ce retournement de situation qui le
favorise ben oui c'est du pain béni pour
lui c'est formidable pour lui là il ne
fait que regarder la télévision et il a
envoyé quelques tweets
évidemment et ça suffit d'ailleurs ses
tweets sont assez modérée 1
ils demandent l apaisement lydie que le
peuple iranien est un lui cet exemple
voilà donc il demande au régime de ne
pas donc en gros tiré dans la foule
c'est ce qu'il a dit récemment il a
laissé entendre
donc pour lui il rien faire dans cette
affaire dans cette histoire
l'erreur vient de l'iran qui a donc tiré
sur une audience civile une faute
grossière quand même pour une armée qui
se présentait comme comme comme étant à
la pointe du progrès en ce qui concerne
la balistique
donc on peut s'interroger sur sur deux à
partir de ce moment là sur sur les
capacités iraniennes à a bien maîtrisé
six missiles et donc voilà donc si tu
perds me dis je le répète pour pondre le
trump
merci beaucoup aux patrick forestier
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france est resté avec nous dans quelques
instants nous recevrons notre invité
politique majid el guerrab député des
français établis hors de france
de nous
il
d
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois ses sentiments
que vous avez eue vous aussi ce besoin
d'autonomie
oui complètement besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes poussent le fait de vivre
avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
pour faire partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces genres de projets qui se fait pas
tout seul dans son coin on est dans un
truc vraiment de coopération de partage
de partage comme
pato se donnant pas seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre 20h30 en direct sur
rt france et pour décrypter l'actualité
nous sommes avec eux majid el guerrab
ex-député la république en marche au
député des français établis hors de
france maghreb et afrique de l'ouest de
la 9e circonscription c'est notre invité
politique ce soir bonsoir
mj de l g merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france ô et venez de
macron donc et les présidents de cinq
pays un sahélien qui ont commencé à
débattre aujourd'hui des moyens de
renforcer leur coopération militaire et
de mobiliser de nouveaux alliés à titre
personnel qu'est ce que vous attendez
professionnels évidemment également
qu'attendez-vous de ce sommet moi
j'attends des clarifications
j'attends qu'on remette à plat la
présence française et surtout la
relation avec les pays concernés et
surtout qu'on puisse ouvrir encore
davantage à des pays tiers la
possibilité de venir s'engager dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme parce que
c'est la sphère de tous ça n'est pas un
pré carré français ça n'est pas comme on
l'entend dire si elle a une nouvelle
forme de colonisation
absolument pas je crois que lutter
contre le terrorisme c'est la sphère de
tous les européens c'est la sphère du
monde alors on entend que les russes
seraient intéressés que les américains
se retirent
d'autres puissances étrangères
voudraient venir
qu'elles viennent et surtout aujourd'hui
on va mettre en place je crois à l'issue
de ce sommet la possibilité aussi de
de financer de s'engager et puis surtout
d'avoir un réceptacle pour accueillir
toutes ses forces étrangères qui
voudraient s'engager dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme au sahel
sauf que vous le savez c'est pas l'avis
de tout le monde de nombreuses voix en
afrique demande tout simplement le
retrait de la france c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu emmanuel macron en préambule
de son sommet a dit moi je veux des
réponses c'est ce que notre présence est
utile il est ce qu'on a besoin de nous
est ce qu'on doit rester vous les
comprenez quand même ces voix qui boot
absolument il ya une impatience qui voit
le jour et on peut le comprendre on un
citoyen normal y voit une puissance avec
une des armées les plus puissantes du
monde
patiner ne pas réussir à s'en sortir
mais il faut il faut comprendre que vu
les distances vu la superficie vu les la
disproportion des forces et surtout la
complexité qui lie à lutter contre ces
formes de terrorisme là aujourd'hui
la france a est d' nos amis de l'afrique
et du sahel à être plus stable mais elle
ne peut pas tout et il faut pour aussi
arrêter avec cette suspicion se sait
complotisme qu'on entend il faut
réaffirmer parce que ses revenus on a eu
des invités ici même des journées cette
afrique imploser mais oui mais on nous
accuse les français de colonialisme 200
euros de voile à cette vieille
françafrique me répondez quoi
mais déjà nous
dans l'ambiance de ma circonscription
vous savez moi je suis député du maghreb
et de l'afrique de loisirs est ce que je
suis très souvent sur cette
circonscription et je l'entends 7
francophobie
cette haine de la france s'exprime est
de plus en plus monter cette ce
sentiment anti français c'est ce qui
exaspérait c'est sur le maghreb et
l'afrique de l'ouest
il entend vraiment monter mais la
meilleure des choses c'est d'abord de la
comprendre de l'entendre et d'essayer
d'y répondre
la première des réponses et de
réaffirmer clairement les raisons pour
lesquelles nous sommes aujourd'hui
présents dans cette zone de l'afrique
quand on aura réaffirmer clairement et
que la volonté des états aura été
clairement exprimées et que la france
aura reçu un nouveau mandat dans le
cadre de sa présence et qu'on aura
réussi à aligner un peu toutes les
mêlées volonté tous les objectifs des
différents pays parce qu'il ya aussi ça
quand vous avez cinq pays qui eux-mêmes
ont des regards différents les uns sur
les autres et que vous venez pour
essayer de stabiliser toute la zone
c'est très très compliqué donc
aujourd'hui il faut réaligner tout le
monde essayait d'avoir des objectifs
communs et à loger 5 sahel qui monte en
puissance il faut le former le financer
on a des outils pour cela il ya beaucoup
de promesses de dons qui ont été fait
aujourd'hui moi je fais partie des
optimistes
je crois que la bataille militaire nous
allons la gagner
par contre dans 5 ans 10 ans en tout cas
nous la gagnerons vu les masses d'argent
qui vont être investis et vu la force
des puissances militaires en présences
nous gagnerons la bataille militaire
c'est une certitude
par contre il restera la bataille
culturelle
il restera à la bataille de l'éducation
et restera la bataille du développement
et c'est là où je crois qu'on attend
aussi beaucoup de la france et la france
aujourd'hui
elle va se montrer elle doit se montrer
au rendez vous pourquoi on attend de la
france au niveau culturel est ce que ce
n'est pas à l'afrique de gérer elle même
ça c'est ce que c'est ce que par exemple
nous avons fait j'étais à abidjan avec
le président de la république il ya deux
trois semaines le président de la
république a annoncé la fin du franc cfa
donc aujourd'hui la france ne battra
plus monnaies pour les états africains
de la zone du franc cfa et ils auront
ils ont leur propre mené tous les points
qui sont aujourd'hui en litige ou alors
qu'ils donnent le sentiment de cette
forme de néo colonisation
enfin il faut les prendre les uns après
les autres essayez des réponses et un
grand malentendu parce que c'est vrai
qu'on entend aussi voilà les français
sont intéressés par les ressources
d'uranium sur les terres il c'est un
malentendu tout ça plus que moi je pense
que c'est plus qu'un malentendu c'est
une incompréhension et moi
quand je vois d'autres puissances
étrangères et la manière dont elles
elles investissent en afrique il n'ya
aucune valeur ajoutée pour les peuples
africains la france quand elle est
présente et que elle elle construit un
pont elle fait travailler des africains
et des africaines et des entreprises
africaines
aujourd'hui quand on voit d'autres
puissances notamment asiatiques qui
viennent et qui investissent et qu'il
n'y a aucune valeur ajoutée pour les
populations locales
maintenant voilà à à nous de faire en
sorte que ces fonds ne soient plus
construit par des puissances étrangères
et c'est là où il faut investir dans
l'éducation la formation pour que ce
soit les africains qui construisent
eux-mêmes leurs ponts et construisent
eux-mêmes leurs universités leur école
et qui se prennent en main en donnant en
rendant les réserves de change pour
que les états africains plus battre leur
monnaie est créée ce qui ce qui est ce
qui a été annoncé
c'est à dire l'écho je crois que c'est
la plus belle des manières de dire
clairement
vous êtes vous êtes maître de votre
propre destin et la france est là comme
un partenaire d'égal à égal est là pour
vous accompagner
ça va sans doute vous faire plaisir
parce qu'une alerte vient de tomber en
annonçant que la france et ces pays du
g5 20 effectivement renforcer leur
coopération militaire anti jihadi
c'était pas gagné parce qu'encore une
fois en préambule emmanuel macron a posé
la question de la présence française
alors que dans le même temps les états
unis annoncent vouloir réduire cette
présence d'ailleurs les présidents des
pays d'ussel souhaite la poursuite de
l'appui crucial des etats-unis il est
effectivement important cet appui est ce
que la france va s'en sortir seul parce
que dans le même temps donc la france
annonce ce renforcement de la
coopération et les etats-unis s'en vont
c'est fondamental aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'eux des états unis pour faire
décoller les drones on a besoin
la technologie américaines pour
combattre contre les djihadistes si les
états unis se retirent je vous avoue que
même au plus haut sommet de l'état on
est très inquiet et je suis pas certain
que ça aille dans le sens des intérêts
des américains parce que penser qu'en se
retirant d'afrique et que tout ça ne les
regarde pas je crois que l'histoire
récente nous a démontré que les
djihadistes les forces terroristes
pouvaient taper même sur le sol c'est
une tendance très américaine en ce
moment l'irad mais voilà ils ont
rétropédaler mais enfin voilà la
tendance ne va pas
le maintien des troupes en syrie en irak
et là en afrique
c'est une grave erreur selon vous de
l'année tron la meilleure manière de
répondre à l'irrationalité c'est d'être
rationnel pour deux la meilleure manière
de répondre à l'outrance c'est d'être
droit et respectueux pour deux voilà moi
je l'encouragé jeudi de manière un peu
disons désabusé que voilà le temps va
passer de nouvelles élections on se se
produire aux états unis nous verrons ce
que le peuple américain décidera mais
est finalement on s'en rend compte
les élections américaines concernent le
monde est donc maintenant il va falloir
que chacune et chacun d'entre nous
regardions de près ce qui se passe au
aux états unis parce que ça n'est plus
ça n'est plus possible d'avoir cette
manière un peu erratique de de ne pas
respecter 2-2 pas respectée dans ses
engagements de ne pas tenir sa parole
d'être dans la provocation quasi
quotidiennes voilà on a besoin d'un
monde apaisé d'un monde stable et moi
j'encourage même à ce que l'on revoie je
me trouve aujourd'hui sur un plateau de
télé particulier conviendrait à ce que
la france revoie aussi
ce qu'elle considère comme ses alliés
l'actualité en france dominée par les
retraites les syndicats divisés après le
retrait provisoire de la chp niveau
edouard philippe
l'annoncé samedi si les syndicats
réforme ils se disent plutôt satisfaits
les centrales opposé à l'ensemble de la
réforme des retraites appelle à
poursuivre le mouvement de grève hier
soir chez nos confrères de france 2
douar philippe a averti nous allons
aller jusqu'au bout de la réforme le
premier ministre qui s'est dit déterminé
à équilibrer financièrement régime les
retraites
il appelle les contestataires à prendre
leurs responsabilités et leurs traits de
l'âge pivot de la réforme un bon
compromis face aux demandes des
syndicats c'est l'avis de la porte
parole du gouvernement écoute et nous
avons considéré depuis le début que pour
mettre le régime à l'équilibré
c'était avec une mesure d'âge en
l'occurrence la mise en place d'un âge à
partir duquel il y aurait un bonus et un
malus de manière progressive qu'on
aurait les meilleurs résultats pour les
travailleurs qui à partir de 2022 vont
avoir à 62 ans la possibilité de partir
à la retraite c'est une vraie avancée
c'est extrêmement important en termes de
justice sociale
vous êtes satisfait par les derniers
développements ce retrait de l'ex pivot
qui ne semble pas à régler la situation
absolument nous étions quelques
parlementaires a plaidé en ce sens tout
ce qui peut inquiéter nuire à la qualité
du dialogue et nous avons des syndicats
réformistes qui veulent aller dans le
sens de du de la réforme et surtout dans
le d'ici 2025
on sait qu'il va y avoir 10 milliards
d'euros de déficit
le soit plus que le budget de la justice
le budget annuel de la justice plus de
10 milliards
donc ils peuvent bien un moment donné ce
falloir se poser les questions et des
questions de réformer le système pour
avoir un système qui je le pense
nous être plus juste plus plus
égalitaire et surtout permettre dans la
responsabilité qui est celle des
décideurs politiques qui doit être celle
des décideurs politiques d'être
autofinancé aujourd'hui ça ne l'est pas
et je crois que nous devons absolument
parler avec ses syndicats et puis
essayer de trouver des issues
mais surtout écouter le peuple aussi
parce que msi en l'écoutant on retire
toi non moi je pense que le si on écoute
le peuple quand vous regardez les
sondages d'opinion que les médias
mettent en ligne
on voit que ils veulent une réforme et
pas n'importe qu'elle préfère c'est là
un pas nommément le vrai forme
ils ne veulent pas n'importe quelle
réforme et vol si vous dites et c'est
pour ça que c'est un peu compliqué c'est
que quand vous avez des gens qui eux qui
manifestent avec des intérêts totalement
différents mais qui manifestent contre
c'est compliqué de 2,2 discuté par les
coins de la cgt la cfdt parle sont
exacts exactement par contre quand vous
avez des syndicats je crois qu'il ya des
syndicats réformistes qui veulent la
réforme
en tout cas quand vous avez des
représentants des salariés qui vous
disent nous voulons la réforme mais ne
voulons pas n'importe quelles réformes
mais nous ne voulons pas des oukases et
et donc nous voulons débattre et nous
voulons prendre cette réforme en main
donnons leur mettons leur fasse aussi à
leurs responsabilités
et moi je pense que effectivement il
fallait revenir sur sur sur l'âge pivot
avons été nombreux à le dire maintenant
que l'âge pivot n'est pas émis de côté
on peut enfin débattre
de l'essentiel c'est est ce qu'on a un
régime universel de retraite
est ce que les femmes vont pouvoir
bénéficier de la même retraite que les
hommes est ce que on va pouvoir avoir
une retraite qui soit financée voilà
maintenant rentrons dans le débat de
manière sereine et sans agiter à des
portes
moi je propose même une chose on le
cadre de ce débat puisque tout le monde
est inquiet sur la valeur du point
le monde les français veulent nos
efforts mais ils vous disent nous ne
faisons pas confiance à l'état perd
quatre occasions et ne faisons pas
confiance à l'état parce qu'on le voit
sur le point d'indicé parfois il est
gelé plusieurs années et c'est pour les
fonctionnaires ils ont raison et moi non
plus je ne fais pas confiance à l'état à
ce qu'on appelle bercy alors faisons une
chose moi je propose que dans le cadre
du débat de la réforme constitutionnelle
qui arrive on constitutionnalise en
constitutionnalise tout cela et on
interdise est une règle d'or qui
interdit les déficits qui interdit les
déficits donc de voter des lois en
déficit
très bien maintenant faisons en sorte
que on introduisent dans le cadre d'un
nouveau pacte social
la possibilité pour chaque français qui
arrivent à la retraite d'avoir
d'interdire la baisse de 2,2 de sa
pension voilà et constitutionnalisant le
donc et ce sera un intouchable et une
administration quelle qu'elle soit ne
pourra pas revenir sur sur la valeur du
point
donc voila moi j'ai dit qu'il protège et
il faut mettre en place un débat serein
apaisé
merci beaucoup m jid el guerrab d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
aux députés donc des français établis
hors de france merci à vous merci la
proposition du gouvernement de retirer
provisoirement on en parle est un lâche
pivot os 64 ans ne satisfait pas tous
les syndicats incertains restent
déterminés à poursuivre le mouvement de
contestation et appellent à de nouvelles
actions
les 14 15 et 16 janvier prochains les
précisions en images
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et à lyon les avocats ont manifesté au
ski ce matin toujours contre cette
réforme des retraites conséquence le
procès de l'ex prêtre bernard prennent a
poursuivi pour agression sexuelle sur
mineur a été reportée à demain
une mobilisation cours de laquelle les
avocats ont formé réchaud s avec leur
code de procédure pénale devant une
salle d'audience du tribunal et pour en
parler nous sommes avec xavier hôtes un
avocat membre justement du collectif sos
retraite bonsoir xavier autun merci
d'être avec nous réunion aujourd'hui de
vos représentants ont reçu par la
ministre de la justice madame b lombez
vous avez des nouvelles de cette réunion
à ce qui a eu des avancées pour vous non
y a pas d'avancée vous avez fait quoi
alors avec elle vient on lui a rappelé
que bâtiment où nous étions nous dans
une situation avec un régime autonome
comme un certain nombre d'autres
libéraux un régime où nous ne coûtons
rien à la collectivité où nous abandon
l'un dernière auteur d'une centaine de
millions d'euros à la solidarité
nationale
en plus de l'aide juridictionnelle donc
nous ne coûtons rien nous donnons de
l'argent et donc nous demandons juste à
garder cette autonomie on a appelé cela
madame le ministre et on lui a demandé
quelles mesures concrètes
elle pouvait nous apporter et je crois
que le panier vide
donc le gouvernement la semaine dernière
nous a déjà proposé rien du vide du
néant
il a réussi à mettre tous les bars ou
dans la rue il a réussi le gouvernement
à faire voter une grève part à
l'intégralité des 164 barreau français
c'est une victoire historique pour le
gouvernement jamais les avocats n'ont
été aussi unanime est aussi opposée à
quelques gouvernements que ce soit les
ordres des avocats existe en france
depuis sept à huit siècles alors vous
avez ôté un poids bien que l'on
comprenne parce que c'est pas toujours
le cas de tous les téléspectateurs parce
que c'est technique vous c'est une
caisse autonome dans laquelle vous avez
cotisé en tant qu'avocat et aujourd'hui
j'oserais dire peut être légitimement
vous avez du mal à comprendre pourquoi
voilà ce régime qui se porte bien qui a
engrangé des millions 100 millions vous
l'avez dit va dans le pot commun
effectivement qui va beaucoup moins bien
à ce que ces résumés ou je suis trop
vite et je vais porter canin non mais
c'est pourquoi je comprenne ce qu'est ce
que c'est dans ma séquence est vous avez
raison il ya entendu parfois c'est à
l'abîmé technique nous disons pas d'un
régime sanction jugent parfois peut-être
privilégié absolument on nous juge
régulièrement comme étant des nantis
alors qu'il ya une très grande disparité
de situations et de revenus dans
l'ensemble des 70 me d'avocats français
nous sommes une caisse autonome
c'est-à-dire qu'à la fin de la guerre
cantons ont créé le régime vieillesse on
met les professions libérales à part on
leur dit vous avez un statut un peu
particulier on va t'en vous m avec les
fonctionnaires ou les salariés vous êtes
à part vous êtes des indépendants et
depuis 70 ans est effectivement des
indépendants auto est à dire qu on
abonde à notre propre caisse et on
reçoit de notre propre caisse comme
cette caisse est excédentaire
nous avons donc nous abondons aux autres
caisses c'est à dire que nous donnons
les 100 millions par an sont 100
millions que les avocats donne aux
autres caisses pour compenser pour
participer la solidarité nationale au
cours des trente dernières années nous
avons fait 2 milliards de réserves mais
au cours des trente dernières années
nous avons reversé un milliard sept
d'ailleurs qu'on a un équilibre entre
les réserves qu'on a fait et la
participation la solidarité nationale ce
que nous proposent au gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est la chose suivante il
me dit vous allez vous retrouver dans un
régime universel vous serai à l'instar
des salariés les fonctionnaires
qu'est ce que ça change pour nous
concrètement nos cotisations retraite
qui sont 14% aujourd'hui vont passer à
28 elles vont
nos cotisations ce qu'on va payer pour
payer en fait et nos droits à retraite
notre minimum à nous et à 1300 et des
brouettes
il va passer à 1000 dire qu'on va payer
plus cher pour avoir moins de retraite
et pour perdre l'autonomie qui est un
des corollaires de l'indépendance des
avocats a pourtant les la garde des
sceaux vous dire les avocats ont des
craintes qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
alors la garde des sceaux nous disent
les uns au coeur des contes qu'on n'est
pas des êtres parce qu'en fait ils
prennent des hypothèses qui sont des
hypothèses inexistant qui prennent des
moutons à cinq pattes 1 le rapport de
monsieur delevoye avait fait avait pris
le cas d'un avocat mais qui n'existe pas
parce que c'est un avocat qui dès sa
première année avec 40000 euros de
revenus alors des avocats qui ont
quarante mille euros de revenus la
première année il y en a pas beaucoup il
commençait sa carrière à 23 ans
les avocats commencent leur carrière à
27 28 ans donc y cotiser plus longtemps
que les autres avec des sommes
fantaisistes donc effectivement la fin
il trouvait que le système était
bénéficiaire mais c'est pas le cas et ce
doublement des cotisations retraites va
impacter concrètement les plus jeunes de
nos de nos confrères et aussi ceux qui
ont les situations économiques les plus
précaires
or ce sont eux qui assume l'aide
juridictionnelle en france ce sont eux
qui aide à l'accès au droit
l'accès des plus démunis à la justice si
vous augmentez les cotisations retraite
de ces gens dont les situations sont
économiquement parfois compliqué et bien
vous allez les mettre au bord du dépôt
de bilan voire en dépôt de bilan et ils
ne pourront plus demain répondre à cette
mission d'aidé juridictionnelle pour
laquelle nous donnons déjà de notre
temps puisque ce que ce que verse l'état
à la durée dictionnaire relève le plus
souvent de l'aumône que de la
rémunération réelle des efforts faits
alors votre prêt à navailles négociation
c'était l'abandon du projet de régime
universel c'est encore le cas où vous
avez reculé sur ta non nous n'avons pas
reculé l'assemblée générale du conseil
national des barreaux dont je suis
membre a noté vendredi la même
résolution c'est-à-dire conserver notre
autonomie conserver le fait que les
charges qui sont sur notre dos
n'augmentent pas et que les garanties de
revenus soit les mêmes hussein nous
avons la chance d'avoir un régime qui
est égalitaire hommes-femmes
le gouvernement dit ah je vais inventer
un système égalitaire femmes nous c'est
déjà le cas chez nous chez les avocats
c'est l'égalité hommes-femmes
nous avons ces régimes de retraite où le
minimum et je voulais dit
1350 euros au lieu des 1000 donc on est
jamais qu est bien plus intéressant le
président la république à rodez vous
avez dire mais vous avez une démographie
qui fait que bientôt vous serez comme
les agriculteurs
il est mal renseigné il faut qu'ils
reviennent vers nous on va le conseiller
il sera bien enseigner on n'a pas du
tout la démographie des agriculteurs on
est de plus en plus nombreux et on reste
moins nombreux que dans tous les grands
pays européens alors un fait rare vous
l'avez dit vous-même pour être souligné
les avocats qui désertent les salles
d'audience on le disait tout à l'heure
vous allez continuer ce type d'action
oui c'est la première fois je voulais
dire autant de bars où tous les barreaux
français des 164 sont en grève avec des
actions de renvoi d'absence de
commissions d'office d'absence d'aidé
juridictionnelle d'absence dans les
garde à vue où on fait même pour
certains cas de la grève du zèle
la grève du zèle ça veut dire que là où
normalement il ya un avocat pour plaider
le dossier mais là il y en a 15 et ont
plein le dossier 15 fois plus longtemps
pour montrer que nous pouvons apporter
du soutien de qualité en permanence et
même quand nous sommes en grève je vais
vous poser la question qui fâche
peut-être aviez autun est ce que votre
pouvoir de nuisance est aussi fort que
celui de la ratp ou la sncf pour vous
faire entendre
alors la ratp sncf se font pas entendre
visiblement les danseurs se font à peu
entendre les pilotes se font taper
entendre nous pas encore nous pensons
qu'il est très important que le
gouvernement par son attitude bloc le
gouvernement réussit à mettre les
avocats dans la rue dans un nombre qui
n'a jamais été amis on a réussi à mettre
les avocats en colère parce qu'il n'a
pas de réponse
donc oui nous continuerons oui nous
serons inflexible car je crois que c est
optimiste sur le fait d'être entendu non
je suis donne d'un optimisme très
raisonnée ne soyons ne soyons pas mais
je crois que le gouvernement de
comprendre que la place des avocats dans
un régime démocratique est fondamental
est que d'attaquer les avocats de ne pas
leur permettre d'exercer convenablement
d'exercer dans des garanties notamment
économiques d'indépendance est une
atteinte à la démocratie et qu'ils
doivent nous entendre savez on
régulièrement monsieur philippe dit on
je reçois et partenaires sociaux je
reçois les syndicats je ne sois le
patronat on n'entend jamais parler des
professions libérales
on est un million en france et on a un
million de salariés à peu près deux
millions d'actifs ça devrait pouvoir
compter merci xavier autun d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et
dans quelques instants les deux rivaux
du conflit
bien fayez élevage le chef du
gouvernement d'union basée à tripoli et
le maréchal haftar l'homme fort de l'est
libyen sont à moscou pour des
discussions cruciales
et puis nous parlerons aussi de l'iran
où l'indignation de la population après
les aveux des autorités sur le crash du
boeing de la compagnie ukrainienne
airlines restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
le
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de ses
caches consacré cette semaine à vos
prévisions olivier quand je fais des
scénarios je le souhaite pas forcément
on a toujours ce problème avec la chine
qui essaie de lutter contre l'hégémonie
américaine
c'est paradoxalement je pense que la
chine est plus dangereux que l'iran je
pense qu'on est un pays qui est aux
abois vous savez quand les guerres se
déclenchent elles se déclenche toujours
parce que les gens ils n'y ont intérêt à
être 4e prévisions à le break cité un
éclatement de la zone euro non moi je
crois pas du tout à un éclatement de la
zone euro et j'attends même avec une
certaine impatience l'entrée de l'ecosse
dans la zone euro alors je ne sais pas
si les causes va rétablir la frontière
est embêté la reine d'angleterre mais en
revanche l'union européenne va avoir
quelques soucis en 2020 mais c'est bien
dit la crise est derrière nous bon bah
ouais donc la crise de l'euro est
derrière nous donc les phéniciens
je sais que pour olivier s'ils savaient
faire vibrer
un bon sapeur c'est quelqu'un de tours
successifs
je vous dirais déjà à paris sans
prétention qu au jour ne pouvait faire
tous les kilomètres vous devrez pas
quelqu'un on obtenu en plein mois de
novembre à bien comme ça j'aime double
sauf l'anonymat l'anonyme avait surmonté
ce poids tu viens de chez toi tu vas au
boulot tu reviens personne a dit
monsieur ou madame vous êtes et les
gaulois la vie est belle en couleurs
pourquoi diable bleu vous vous vous vous
allez tous au noir bleu marine j'ai dû
nous c'est pas possible ça sert à rien
l'habille le sapeur fait jouer à l'ebit
son premier rôle chris pine ce qui ne
devait pas cessé d'être un vecteur de
communication
mais la sape pas cessé de vivre ensemble
via la bi
je suis venu ici pour essayer de plonger
à la limite de mes capacités
je n'aime pas le froid c'est un défi en
quelque sorte
essayez de plonger dans l'eau glacée
oh la vache quoi
ce type qui a battu le record du monde
il a fait une autre plongée à 75 m je
dois plongé à 76 3 2 à départ
[Musique]
l'huile de palme est l'un des produits
les plus controversées de notre temps
c'est une graisse végétale solide et
elle est très bon marché
en 2017 la production a atteint un
sommet de 63 millions de tonnes cette
croissance rapide de la demande globale
d'huile peu coûteuse a causé une
expansion massive des plantations de
palmiers à huile
ce qui entraîne à son tour la
destruction de la forêt tropicale
[Musique]
dans la seule indonésie plus de dix
millions d'hectares de forêts primaires
ont été détruits et cela se poursuit
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous si vous nous rejoignez
merci nous rejoindre donc pour cette
deuxième heures d'émission en direct eu
rt france tout de suite voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce lundi l' issue
diplomatique est elle encore possible en
libye c'est en tout cas ce à quoi
s'attelle moscou sergueï lavrov a reçu
aujourd'hui les deux rivaux libyen à
l'ifa haftar et failli s est la rage ce
dernier chef du gouvernement reconnu par
l'onu a signé un document concrétisant
le cessez-le-feu d'hyères le premier lui
prend le temps d'y réfléchir
rappelons que ce cessez le feu doit
servir de prélude à une conférence
internationale sur la libye le 19
janvier prochain le gouvernement iranien
nie avoir tenté de masquer la
responsabilité des autorités dans le
crash de l'avion de ligne ukrainien
battu par erreur près de téhéran lui
janvier un drame qui suscite la colère
dans le pays où des manifestations anti
gouvernementales ont lieu les présidents
des pays du sahel souhaite la poursuite
de l'appui crucial des états unis la
france et le g5 ça elles vont renforcer
leur coopération militaire anti
jihadistes on apprend cela à l'issue de
cette journée de réunions à pau autour
d' emmanuel macron quels sont les enjeux
de cette rencontre alors que le
sentiment anti français progresse la
présence de notre pays est elle toujours
souhaitable utile et légitime la france
doit-elle changer de stratégie ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face à 21h30
[Musique]
des progrès ont donc été notées sur la
crise en libye selon le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
qui a reçu aujourd'hui à moscou le chef
du gouvernement libyen a reconnu par
l'onu fayez al azhar âge et son rival
halifax tard l'homme fort de l'est
libyen
fayez l asa âge qui refuse de rencontrer
physiquement son rival a signé un accord
sur les modalités du cessez le feu entré
en vigueur hier un cessez le feu qui
intervient alors que la turquie ait
déployé des hommes en soutien à ce
dernier
les précisions avec les îles à saraf des
progrès de l'optimisme voilà ce qui
ressort de ces négociations à moscou
sept heures de discussions d'un côté le
chef du gouvernement libyen reconnu par
l'onu
fayez elle sa rage de l'autre l'homme
fort de l'est
le maréchal khalifa haftar oui mesdames
et messieurs nous tenons à vous informer
des progrès atteint à l'heure actuelle
chester aujourd'hui dès le matin des
consultations intenses avec vos parties
diène qui avec le soutien des ministres
turcs et russes des affaires étrangères
et de la défense a été examiné un
document qui permettra de concrétiser
les questions liées au régime au cessez
le feu deux pays se sont imposés ces
dernières semaines comme des acteurs
clés en libye la turquie ainsi déployer
des militaires ce mois de janvier pour
soutenir la géhenna de fayat zèle sa
rage de son côté la russie a tenu à
s'engager dans une médiation entre les
deux camps afin d'éviter une situation
comme en séries le maréchal haftar
commandant de l'armée nationale libyenne
et le président de la chambre des
représentants de tobrouk
monsieur aguilas à les uns considèrent
le document positivement et demande un
peu de temps supplémentaire jusqu'à
demain matin pour décider de le signer
et j'espère que cette décision sera
positive
la signature d'un accord formel de
cessez le feu ne pourrait donc être
qu'une question de temps afin de
pérenniser une très fragile dans un pays
en proie au chaos depuis l'intervention
militaire de 2011 et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis londres avec ayo
johnson john et les spécialistes de
l'afrique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir
joe johnson merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france à leur niveau un
diplomate hic les russes et les turcs
sont en première ligne dans ce dossier
libyen est ce qu'on peut dire pour
l'instant que ce sont les les deux
gagnants voilà de cette crise clairement
il ya eu des progrès ces derniers jours
en effet il ya eu des progrès au cours
des derniers jours
les turcs notamment soutiennent sa rage
qui est le dirigeant de le chef de la
capitale tripoli entourée par le
maréchal haftar et ses troupes qui
domine de grandes portions du pays la
turquie elle sur le terrain pour
soutenir al sa rage à juste titre à
tripoli après ce qu était prise par des
troupes du maréchal afar d'ailleurs il
semble que la négociation est le seul
moyen de prévenir une carte complète qui
pourrait toucher des milliers voire des
millions de personnes dans le pays
est ce qu'il est en risque selon vous
vous écoutez en tout cas que la libye
devienne une sorte de nouvelle série
absolutely tout à fait il ya des
similitudes le conflit syrien comme nous
le savons a été
vraiment cruel très chaotique beaucoup
de personnes ont été déplacées beaucoup
de personnes ont perdu la vie
nous avons vu des factions qui n'ont
jamais réussi à contrôler le pays en
entier au niveau international également
beaucoup de pays étaient impliqués
soutenez un côté ou l'autre et cela rend
la situation très complexe
c'est la même chose en libye le scénario
est similaire nous avons deux dirigeants
monsieur haftar est fayez al sa rage qui
ne trouvent pas de points communs qui
est se battent pour leur pays mais au
prix de leurs peuples eux et de beaucoup
de femmes et d'enfants déplacés et nous
avons également l'application de
beaucoup de pays extérieurs qui
soutiennent le maréchal haftar qui
contrôlent une grande portion du pays et
de l'autre côté il ya al sa rage qui est
reconnu par l'onu et qui est le chef du
gouvernement reconnu par l'onu dans ce
pays et qui ne contrôle que la capitale
nous avons également devant donc d en
commun entre la syrie et la libye où il
ya deux factions qui ne réussissent pas
tombés d'accord et un aspect également
international vous venez nous décrire
très bien cette situation entre deux
personnages qui ont vraiment peur
d'affinités c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire est ce que vous voyez un compromis
viable à long terme et nous sommes comme
ça c'est dingue de telles circonstances
avec les complexités que nous avons
constaté le compromis le dialogue et
les conférences du type qui ont été
arrangées par moscou et la turquie les
bases d'une conversation et d'un accord
qui peuvent devenir comme qu'on accable
un accord entre les deux dirigeants
avec l'idée qu'autour d'eux il ya des
gens qui leur demandent de résoudre
leurs différences en évitant les armes
oui effectivement cela fait longtemps
que le conflit existe c'est vrai que
beaucoup de personnes ne sont plus
scolarisés les institutions
gouvernementales ne fonctionnent plus
correctement et il y a eu des pertes
humaines mais il s'agit d'éviter une
guerre totale et une guerre totale pour
être un impact terrible sur la libye si
c'est conversation n'arrive pas à terme
il y aura une conférence internationale
sur la libye à berlin sous l'égide de
l'onu le 19 janvier
est ce qu'on peut en attendre quelque
chose et si oui quoi iphone ce week-end
expect qu'ils font un stage de danse
c'est ce qu'on peux t'attendre ainsi la
conférence d'aujourd'hui a ouvert sur un
cessez le feu et pourra également
espérer tomber sur des termes en commun
fayez sara ge pourrait demander à
demander que monsieur haftar reviennent
à la position qu'il avait avant cette
série d'expansion tels que en tout cas
ça y est ça le serrage de considère qu
il est très difficile de voir comment on
pourrait trouver une solution mais j'ai
confiance je pense qu'avec
l'intervention des russes il pourrait y
avoir du succès merci à hugh johnson
journaliste spécialiste de l'afrique
d'avoir été avec nous pour notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir deux
jours après avoir reconnu sa culpabilité
dans le crash du boeing 737 d'ukrainiens
airlines le gouvernement
iraniens nient aujourd'hui avoir tenté
d'étouffer la faire une déclaration en
réponse aux manifestations
antigouvernementales qui ont éclaté ce
week-end un peu partout dans le pays
une pression de la rue donc mais aussi
international le premier ministre
canadien demande des réponses de son
côté l'émir du qatar en visite à téhéran
tente d'apaiser les tensions
françois davy lambert avec mehdi et ski
fis l'émir du qatar revêt ses habits de
médiateur alors que doha entretient de
bonnes relations avec l'iran
tamim al-thani a rencontré le président
iranien et le guide suprême
l'occasion pour l'émir d'exhorter les
différents acteurs à un apaisement des
tensions
hassan rohani s'est de son côté montré
plus mesuré que lors de ses dernières
déclarations à l'encontre des états unis
en raison de l'importance que nous
accordons à la sécurité régionale en
particulier concernant les voies
navigables du golfe persique et le
détroit d'ormuz et de la mer dauman nous
avons décidé de mener davantage de
négociations et de confrontation pour la
sécurité de l'ensemble de la région
cette visite intervient à montrer
critique dans la région
nous avons convenu avec mon frère et
avec son excellence le président en
compagnie de la seule solution à ces
crises résidents la désescalade
le dialogue est la seule solution à ces
crises de son côté le porte parole du
gouvernement iranien ali rabier a tenu
ce lundi à prévenir les états unis des
iraniens ont bien l'intention de ne pas
céder face à leur rival américain est
inégal les américains nous donne des
messages qui n'ont rien à voir avec les
autres et veulent nous parler
directement
nous n'avons pas confiance en eux
s'ils lèvent les sanctions et supprime
la pression sur notre peuple nous
parlerons et nous pensons que ce single
hors saison du terrain et intensifierons
encore plus leur pression
malheureusement nous n'avons pas été en
mesure d'expliquer clairement aux gens
pourquoi nous résistons aux états unis
donald trump n'est pas digne de
confiance
ils pensent qu'en mettant les gens
ordinaires sous pression big lots
obtenir ce qu'il veut il nous forcer à
battre en retraite
ortega y gasset malgré des discours
diplomatique plus aisés la population
iranienne continue de manifester dans
les rues de téhéran des dizaines de
personnes se sont ainsi réunis devant
l'ambassade du royaume uni au lendemain
de la brève arrestation de l'ambassadeur
britannique
ce dernier avait été accusée d'avoir
pris part à un rassemblement à la
mémoire des victimes
un hommage jugées illégales par téhéran
il saisit d'une manifestation contre
l'ingérence des années dans les affaires
des autres et à la tête de la base
aérienne américaine constitue un coup
dur pour eux nos amis profitent
généralement des troubles internes pour
se venger et tromper l'opinion publique
et ses manifestations contre les
dirigeants iraniens ont continué pour
leur demander de rendre des comptes
après la destruction du boeing
d'ukrainiens airlines la presse locale
n'a d'ailleurs pas ménagé le pouvoir
qualifiant la destruction de l'avion d'
acte impardonnable
les tensions restent également forte sur
le plan militaire cinq jours après deux
premières frappes iranienne sur des
bases en irak
plusieurs roquettes d'origine
indéterminée aurait à nouveau visé un
camp abritant des soldats américains
indigné par les informations sur une
nouvelle attaque à la roquette contre
une base aérienne irakienne
je prie pour un prompt rétablissement
des blessés et j'exhorte le gouvernement
d'irak à tenir responsables ceux qui
sont derrière cette attaque contre le
peuple irakien
loin de cette démonstration de force
toronto rendait hommage aux 57 victimes
canadiennes de l'accident
près de 2000 personnes se sont réunies
pour une cérémonie commémorative
très ému le premier ministre canadien a
promis aux familles des victimes que
justice sera rendue
et pour en parler nous sommes avec à
drieu godefridi hauteur de la révolution
trump et de reload comment les mairies
qu'un oncle siècle à paraître demain aux
éditions t'excuses bonsoir drieu
godefridi merci d'avoir effectué en
direct sur arte france tout d'abord ces
iraniens aujourd'hui qui nie avoir caché
des choses concernant cette terrible
erreur à ce que vous croyez que c'est
crédible
c'est à dire que c'est plus grave que ça
c'est un crime abominable qui étaient
commis puisque le régime iranien a
montré son incapacité à faire la
différence entre un bombardier américain
et un avion de ligne civil qui vient de
déclarer son décollage à la tour de
contrôle de teyran donc il est difficile
de faire clooney je veux dire on a vu
des fanatiques beaucoup plus compétents
que ceux qui sont actuellement au
pouvoir et donc finalement qu'il y ait
eu au départ des velléités de cacher des
responsabilités tout ça finalement est
dans la droite ligne d'une catastrophe
dans la gestion de ce régime
il faut rappeler que juste auparavant il
y a eu 40 iraniens qui sont morts parce
qu'ils se sont ils se sont piétinées
étant donné que le régime avait fermé
les rues les accès pour créer un effet
de marée humaine lors des obsèques du
général a battu par les américains donc
on est là dans une sorte de festival de
n'importe quoi et et d'incompétents en
jeu 10 e d'un régime qui paraît aux
abois la question est importante
pourquoi parce que il ya des
manifestants dans la rue beaucoup de
jeunes d'ailleurs qu'ils ont perdu voilà
entre guillemets leurs collègues
puisqu'il y avait beaucoup d'étudiants
également dans l'avion est ce que ce
n'est pas le mensonge peut-être le le
pire pour eux et je pense qu on assiste
de manière vraiment fondamental à une
rue
ce tribut sion d'écart puisque vous avez
aujourd'hui un président et une
administration en place aux états unis
qui prend fait et cause a pour le je
dirais le peuple iranien ou pour la
fraction en tout cas du peuple iranien
qui se révolte depuis de longs mois à
voir depuis des années contre le régime
dictatorial tyrannique totalitaire de
nature islamique qui est au pouvoir à
téhéran
donc on a là une donnée parfaitement
neuf puisque à l'époque de monsieur
obama obama traiter avec le régime au
pouvoir à téhéran il n'a pas hésité à
lui envoyer de l'argent compris en cash
plus d'un milliard de de là on allait il
si maintenant un gouvernement américain
dont l' approche est tout à fait
différent vous avez un président
américain qui n'hésitent plus à envoyer
des tweets en farsi de manière à parler
directement aux non plus seulement au
peuple américain mais au peuple iranien
est donc cette nouvelle donne risque
effectivement de conduire à des
évolutions structurelles mais quand je
dis risque c'est ça peut être une
évolution réjouissante
vous dites ça peut conduire à des
évolutions on a vu quand même un grand
moment d'unité à la mort du général
souleymane sy pour vous ce sont deux
iron qui se confrontent où effectivement
cet accident dramatique va être un
tournant qui peut être ira plus loin
dans une révolte peut-être plus profond
plus importante coûter nettement jeu il
me paraît difficile de répondre de
manière catégorique et péremptoire à
cette question il est difficile
aujourd'hui de prévoir ce que seront les
évolutions mais il me semble qu'avec le
soutien américain à ceux quittant la
population je ne sais pas s'ils sont
majoritaires je ne sais pas s'ils
représentent une minorité plus ou moins
importantes mais qui veulent des
évolutions voire une révolution au sein
de l'iran il ya là quelque chose qui
change la donne et que de ce point de
vue là les européens reste je dirai au
bord de la route restent attentistes n'a
finalement plus aucune importance cela
va se jouer
finalement c'est un an une scène à trois
hector il ya le régime iranien qui sur
le plan économique est faible
je rappelle que le pib dire ans cet été
en dessous du pib la belgique dont on
parle d'un tout petit pays en réalité en
terme de capacité avec l'unique va se
jouer entre le régime iranien qui est
faible et aux abois le peuple iranien
est enfin ce gouvernement américain qui
paraît prêt à tout mettre en oeuvre je
dirais pour faciliter l'évacuation du
régime au pouvoir actuellement à téhéran
on doit sa faute et effectivement les
mains donald trump c'était une sortie
inespérée on lisait après ce moment
d'unification
à la mort du général soliman y est ce
que justement qu'elle peut être
l'attitude la de donald trump pour le
sens très apaisée très haut là
étonnamment calme comment vous jugez son
attitude je crois que son attitude
disons sur le plan formel il est il est
égal à lui même qu'il a un côté très fin
très fin faron je dirais très affirmée
mais sur le saas est là fort parce que
sur le fond il est extrêmement fin en
réalité il est très adroit et il parlait
un systématiquement à mettre tous ces
gens en contre-pied et je crois qu'il
doit éprouver un sentiment de très
grande victoire parce qu'il réussit à
provoquer des évolutions considérables
dans ce régime qui explore depuis des
années le terrorisme dans parmi ses
voisins il réussit à provoquer les
évolutions considérables sans coeur
c'est à dire sans avoir il sait quelque
chose qu'il veut éviter
il en a fait le serment depuis sa
campagne qui a débuté en genre à 2015 il
veut éviter d'avoir à envoyer 100 mille
soldats américains comme l'avait fait
par exemple monsieur bush dans ses
origines dans cette région monsieur bush
était évidemment en irak et donc il
parvient à susciter les évolutions
absolument énorme avec un coût
économique et milite
or pour les américains qui est
virtuellement nul est d'accord du
nucléaire dans tout ça parce que
florence parly le rappeler à la ministre
française on oublie peut-être le plus
important selon elle c'est cet accord du
nucléaire iranien dont s'est retirée
évidemment les etats-unis est-ce qu'il a
des chances de ressusciter sa part est
compromis je pense qu'effectivement
c'est terminé maintenant la vraie
question n'est même plus de savoir si
cet accord allait venir en dépit de ce
que racontent les européens mais
finalement qui coûte quitte ou encore
sur la scène internationale ce que
racontent les européens dont les
complicités finalement de feu avec ce
régime soit en chansons sont atroces en
réalité parce que nous avons ici un
régime qui n'hésite pas à utiliser des
les pires méthodes sadique sur sa propre
population il ya eu des massacres
d'iraniens abarca régime et donc
l'attitude des européens me paraît pour
des aliments sains sujette à caution
donc la vraie question cet accord est
mort nous ne pourrons jamais revenir sur
cette accusation d'une expiration en
donc maintenant tous les éléments ont
évolué donc la question n'est plus de
savoir si l'on pourra revenir dans le
cadre de cet accord qui est
définitivement mort et enterré encore un
point sur lequel monsieur très bon en
dépit de son côté fanfaron apparemment
il réfléchit autres peux tu éprouves et
je prends aujourd'hui un sentiment de
victoire sinon de triomphe
la vraie question est de savoir si le
régime actuellement au pouvoir à téhéran
parviendra à se maintenir ce qui saute à
la conclusion inverse en disant non
c'est fini donc la la population va pas
l'emporter
l'iran va devenir ou redevenir une
démocratie vont également à mon avis
beaucoup trop vite n'oublions pas que ce
régime peut s'appuyer sur une fraction
disons significative de la population
iranienne qui partage ses options je
dirais de nature à la fois islamistes et
nationalistes donc on ne peut pas le
prévoir mais c'est aujourd'hui une
question qui se pose alors qu'à l'époque
du gouvernement de monsieur obama qui
finalement à tout faire pour maintenir
ce régime en place la question ne se
posait pas aujourd'hui la question de la
survie
li ti de ce régime totalitaire se pose
vous parlez du régime vous dites oui
l'accord est mort certes mais enfin il
ya le pendant de tout ça c'est la bombe
nucléaire est ce que vous pensez vous
qu'on doit craindre que l'iran se dote
de sept gros mots clairement et vous
savez c'est évidemment la question
centrale vous avez tout à fait raison
à quand on raisonne comme un européen
c'est à dire d'une manière égale et
égalitariste on se dit toutes les
puissances dans la région son sang sont
équivalentes mais en réalité il y fort
hyaric
il faut regarder le la vérité du rapport
de force j'avais ici deux acteurs dans
la région l'amérique dont le budget
année dans le budget militaire de 700
milliards par an maintenant et israël
tout petit pays mais qui a quand même
une certaine puissance de frappe
ce sont deux régimes à présent dans la
région qui sont infiniment plus puissant
que ce que diront on pourra jamais
produit sur le plan militaire et qui ont
pris la décision il y a déjà un certain
nombre d'années de manière très claire
que l'iran ne pourra jamais ce que de la
bombe nucléaire
par conséquent cela n'arrivera pas et
quand on voit la façon dont l'iran avec
son petit matériel militaire régionale
parvient déjà parreira parce que à mon
sens
en tout cas tous les éléments indiquent
aujourd'hui c'est une erreur abattre un
avion civil au dessus de son propre
aéroport on se dit que y compris pour le
peuple iranien il est effectivement
peut-être souhaitable que ces genres
année jamais la bombe nucléaire
merci beaucoup drieu godefridi d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france de
nous avoir apporté votre analyse
des centaines d'indépendantistes catalan
réunis devant le parlement européen à
strasbourg un rassemblement en soutien
car l'esprit du monde qui assistera sa
première session parlementaire ce lundi
l'ancien président de la région catalane
dénonce dans un communiqué une violation
des droits par madrid
un rassemblement pour également dénoncé
l'absence dorion rouquet race l'élu
indépendantiste catalan actuellement
emprisonnés en espagne le 10 septembre
dernier le parlement a adopté la
décision de la cour suprême de lui
retirer son statut de député européen
monsieur d'une cuirasse doit être avec
nous aujourd'hui car il a recueilli
comme nous plus d'un million de voix
mais malheureusement il y à un état
membre de l'union européenne l'espagne
qui ne respectent pas à l'état de droit
en europe et nous sommes ici pour
rappeler que la crise catalan n'est pas
une affaire interne mais une affaire
européenne
toujours en espagne c'est aujourd'hui
que le nouveau gouvernement prête
serment
un gouvernement de coalition les
socialistes ont dû s'allier avec le
parti de gauche radicale podemos une
première depuis 1975 pour obtenir la
confiance des députés le chef de
l'exécutif pedro sanchez a passé un
accord avec les indépendantistes
catalans s'attirant les foudres de la
droite radicale
mathilde romagon c'est une première
depuis la fin de la dictature franquiste
il ya 45 ans
l'espagne aura à sa tête un gouvernement
de coalition le chef de l'exécutif le
socialiste pedro sanchez a dû tendre la
main aux élus de podemos le parti de
gauche radicale sur 22 ministres cinq
sont issus de ce parti le leader de
podemos aura même droit au titre de
quatrième vice-président en charge des
droits sociaux malgré tout pedro sanchez
promet un gouvernement uni et son
gouverneur local
c'est un gouvernement pluraliste c'est
un gouvernement de coalition mais avec
un objectif ferme d'unités c'est un
gouvernement qui va se nourrir l'idée
plurielle mais qui va marcher dans une
seule direction et ces primaires il
s'agit du premier gouvernement de
coalition dans l'histoire de
démocratie il devra suivre une nouvelle
voie qui servira également de référence
pour l'avenir et mettra la politique
espagnole sur la même voie que la
politique européenne politicards et
européens mais ce gouvernement ne s'est
pas mise en place sans quelques
compromis pour être sûr d'avoir la
confiance des députés
pedro sanchez a ainsi négocié avec le
parti séparatiste catalan le rc en
échange de leurs votes il leur a promis
des discussions pour trouver une
solution au conflit politique en
catalogne ce qui a provoqué la colère
des membres de vox le parti de droite
radicale
ils ont appelé dimanche à une
manifestation contre le nouveau
gouvernement qu'il n'estime plus
légitime aujourd'hui comme dans toutes
les mairies des spas nous voulions être
ici avec tous les peuples
convoqué par la plateforme l'espagne
exister pour revendiquer notre nation
revendiquer l'espagne revendiquer notre
souveraineté pour revendiquer notre
constitution et pour dire devant un
usurpateur illégitime du gouvernement du
peuple espagnol que nous sommes ici pour
dire haut et fort que nous ne resteront
pas passifs face à un gouvernement qui a
menti à tous les espagnols
des manifestants qui ont fait face à des
militants anti fascistes et des
partisans de l'indépendance catalane
nul doute que l'avenir de la catalogne
sera au coeur des débats en espagne dans
les prochaines semaines
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
un autre débat sur la présence militaire
française au sahel dans le cadre de
l'opération barkan emmanuel macron vient
d'annoncer un renforcement de la
coopération
de l'armée française et des pays du
sahel on en débattra dans quelques
instants
[Musique]
le handball est il géopolitique
collision il devrait l'être mais ne
l'est pas pour l'instant on voit pas des
personnalités capables de structurer à
la fois du côté business du côté comme
et du côté clairement géopolitique le
hand pour qu'ils soient capables de
rivaliser
non pas avec le foot mais avec les
sports qui sont juste à côté fo constate
qu'il ya des rapports de force entre
états qui se manifeste au travers du
hand et on voit dans l'organisation des
événements dans la manière finalement de
l'est de désigner les pays qui organise
il ya aussi cette dimension géopolitique
il suffit de voir l'adhésion par exemple
des français à l'équipe nationale de
rands pour comprendre qu'il ya aussi
cette dimension de handball doit se
renouveler doit s'internationaliser et
ça ça passera par un changement de
paradigme
au niveau mondial on est sur un sport
qui a une vraie importance à l'échelle
mondiale et là où je suis d'accord c'est
que la globalisation du honda n'est pas
encore achevée la politique à travers le
handball c'est ses doigts tu dois être
une politique pour le handball est plus
la politique pour la politique
[Musique]
alexandre je faisais direct vous êtes
vous déjà dopé il n'y a jamais de ma vie
[Musique]
vous pensiez que la sphère du dopage en
russie était terminée pour vous trompiez
les documents sont arrivés et que j'ai
ouvert le dossier et j'ai eu
l'impression d'être recouverts de boue
la participation des athlètes russes aux
compétitions internationales est en jeu
cela concerne notamment des événements
tels que les jeux olympiques de tokyo et
la coupe du monde de football au qatar
c'est ma médaille je sais que je les
gagne honnêtement je ne me rendrai
jamais comme il ya quatre ans le
laboratoire antidopage de moscou est au
centre de ce scandale
alors qui a modifié la base de données
d'échantillons des sportifs et quel
rapport cela a t-il avec grigoriy
rodtchenko ils ont pu remplacer des
résultats négatifs par des résultats
positifs comme si l'athlète avait déjà
consommé des substances interdites pour
l'approcher par la suite et le faire
chanter pour de l'argent
[Musique]
un cheveu de suite c'était l'enfer et ça
reste à nous faire
quand vous entrez la nuit c'est
effrayant
ce sont les mêmes rails par lesquelles
les juifs y compris ceux de ma famille
ont été transportés de hollande à
auschwitz birkenau
amsterdam rue rollix tracts ont réparé
la maison qui autrefois appartenait aux
parents de file encore le plafond des
toilettes a été démoli par une boîte
contenant des lettres est tombée sur le
sol et la boîte avec les lettres est
tombée sur le sol j'ai grandi sans
savoir grand chose sur ma famille les
lettres de flip nous ont permis d'en
ressentir l'histoire et de comprendre
que je faisais partie après j'ai
découvert que non seulement fier
puisqu'il hier à trouver la mauricie
mais qu'encore 118 autrement de ma
famille ont partagé son destin
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direction
arte france si vous nous rejoignez au
sommet de pau emmanuel macron vient de
re claire clarifier les lions sont
hygiéniste avec ses homologues luge et 5
il annonce un maintien des troupes
françaises de l'opération barkan sur le
terrain avec l'engagement supplémentaire
de 220 soldats sur place ils souhaitent
combattre le djihadisme et soulager les
pays du sahel dans des frontières
spécifiques notamment au mali au niger
et au burkina
quant à eux les présidentes des pays
d'ussel souhaite un renfort des états
unis tout comme emmanuel macron qui
dénonce par ailleurs des puissances
étrangères qui alimente selon lui ce
discours anti français dans la région du
sahel écouter le choix la décision la
demande des états souverains pour
préserver leur souveraineté de faire
appel à des amis à des alliés pour
combattre justement ces groupes armés
terroristes qui sont aujourd'hui une
menace avérée à la souveraineté de
chacun des états où il opère et
aujourd'hui à travers la déclaration que
nous adoptons les chefs d'état du g5 sel
ont exprimé leur souhait de la poursuite
de l'engagement militaire de la france à
travers barkan de nos forces
d'engagement de la présence européenne
et de tous les alliés dans le cadre de
cette coalition
pour atteindre cet objectif nous
changeons la méthode en mettant en place
une coalition militaire avec un
commandement conjoint entre la force
barkan et la force conjointe du g5 celle
en concentrant nos efforts sur cette
zone est donc en intégrant nos forces de
renseignement nos forces militaires sur
cette zone avec eux une attitude
d'engagement beaucoup plus forte au delà
de cela
d'ores et déjà fort de notre convergence
avec les homologues sahélien j'ai décidé
d'engager des capacités de combat
supplémentaires 220 militaires pour
amorcer cette dynamique viendront
gonfler les troupes d'ores et déjà
présentes sur le terrain de barkan tous
les pays partenaires qui le souhaitent
sont les bienvenus pour rejoindre cette
dynamique et en réunissant le g55
manuellement
on espérait redonner une légitimité à la
présence des militaires français
déployés dans la région le point en
images sur la chronologie de ces
déploiements militaires
[Musique]
et en marge de ce sommet un
rassemblement contre la présence
française dans le sel une cinquantaine
de manifestants représentant les pays de
la région et même au dollar ont
manifesté ils réclament le départ des
soldats français de tous nos continents
la liberté est une vraie souveraineté
les manifestants scandent de nombreux
slogans à l'encontre du système français
distille un système de pouvoir selon eux
qu'on en plus comme au temps du
colonialisme à la suite de l'opération
servat albarka n'était donc créer un
pour appuyer les pays du g5 celles
engagées dans la lutte contre les
groupes islamistes affiliés au groupe
etat islamique sept ans après alors que
cette présence française est de plus en
plus critiquée alors est elle légitime
et justifiée faut-il envisager un
retrait des troupes pour relancer
l'alliance anti jo 10 c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec marc antoine pérouse de
montclos auteur du livre une guerre
perdue aux éditions jean claude lattès à
paraître ce mercredi directeur de
recherche également à l'institut de
recherche pour le développement bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous à ses côtés
mériadec raffray secrétaire général de
l'association des journalistes
spécialisés défense auteur de touaregs
la révolte des hommes bleus aux éditions
economica bonsoir à vous aussi merci
d'être là alors on est venu et le
mettront qui a répondu à une partir des
questions qui se posaient avant même ce
sauvés puisque on l'a entendu il annonce
ce soir donc le renforcement de la
coopération française hausse elle envoie
même de 220 soldats supplémentaires
c'est une surprise pour vous on va
commencer par vous marc antoine pérouse
de montclos elle est un vrai show on
attendait pas une révolution de ce
sommet qui rappelez-vous faisait suite
aussi à cet accident de l'hélicoptère
autres cours duquel on avait perdu 13
soldats et qui seront effectivement avec
un sentiment de monter de rejoindre la
présence militaire française je suis pas
sûr que ce sommet va désamorcer cette ce
rejet de la présence militaire française
encore faudrait-il que les présidents
des pays du g5 sahel effectivement fasse
des déclarations claires dans leurs
capitales et pas seulement à pau donc à
voir en sachant que cette ce sentiment
en fait traduit deux choses d'une part
c'est extrêmement humiliant pour
beaucoup d'africains de voir que c'est
l'ancienne puissance coloniale qui doit
se substituer à des armes est
défaillante est compris dans des pays
comme le burkina qui avait une espèce de
tradition révolutionnaire en pays
impérialistes et puis d'autre part ça
exprime la frustration ça fait
maintenant sept ans que la france s'est
engagée d'abord au mali puis dans les
pays voisins
sept ans de réflexion pourquoi les
groupes jihadistes sont toujours
présents le mali est toujours coupée en
deux donc il ya une espèce de
frustration qui en fait est à la mesure
de l'enlisement des troupes françaises
dans la dans la région mériadec raffray
peut-être pas une une révolution il
n'empêche emmanuel macron clairement
avait dit avant ce sommet soit il notre
présence
ont-ils besoin de nous je veux des
réponses claires et assumé sur ces
questions manifestement il y a répondu
puisque il dit oui il réaffirme cette
puissance française part dans cet
engagement français sur place
bon c'est pas une surprise chacun savait
bien que la france n'allait pas se
désengager du sel parce que tout
simplement c'est impossible
jouer simplement rebondir sur les propos
de mon voisin vous le dirai pourquoi
c'est impossible parce que les était
alors oui alors ok je lui répondu à
cette question c'est intéressant
effectivement les américains sont en
train entre une sorte de nous lâcher au
sel reste une surprise on peut en
discuter
les américains en fait appuyé les
français en matière de logistique
ils ont des gros porteurs qui permettent
de faire des manoeuvres aériennes de
transport compliqué disons des avions
qui ravitaille nos chasseurs qui sont en
permanence en l'air ils ont surtout
toute une panoplie de moyens qui leur
permettent de faire du renseignement et
qui viennent alimenter nos propres
capteurs qui sont efficacement droits
limités et donc effectivement si les
américains partent c'est un un vrai
sujet sur lequel planche actuellement
l'elysée les états-majors donc pour
pascal impossible de partir ça alors
pourquoi c'est impossible de partir
écouter on peut prendre une analogie qui
est récente en 2014 il ya ce qu'on
appelle d'âge qui naît en irak sur les
ruines de l'irak qu'ont quitté les
américains en 2011
et voilà ici en fait on part aujourd'hui
c'est globalement ce qui se passera à
vitesse grand v on le voit aujourd'hui
les garnisons ligérienne les garnisons
maliennes sont attaqués en permanence
évidemment parce que l'ennemi ne veut
absolument pas que les armées africaines
prennent le lead prennent l'ascendant et
en particulier ne veulent surtout pas de
cette force du g5 celle qui est en
capacité d'aller de part et d'autre les
frontières et donc de porter le fer dans
le seul le principal à toutes ces deux
séries djihadistes à savoir se jouer des
frontières pour ne pas prêter flanc en
fait aux armées conventionnelles de la
france et est du mali
et donc si on part demain tout le monde
est d'accord pour dire que c'est le
chaos je vous rappelle qu'en 2013 en
janvier enfin à l'été 2013
moi j'étais du côté d'abidjan et je le
mets les ministres nous disait en off
nous avions très peur en janvier 2013
que les djihadistes qui descendait du
nord vers bamako et que l'opération
serval arrête en janvier 2013 ne
continue ensuite jusqu'à la mer voilà en
effet un témoignage autres autres autre
élément pour aller dans ce sens
aujourd'hui on voit bien que cette ce
cancer djihadistes les métastases
djihadistes qui gangrènent aujourd'hui
le sel s'étendent au bénin où la vue en
mai avec l'opération pour délivrer nos
otages qui avait été pris dans les
forêts du nord du bénin
plus tôt en 2016 à grand bassam qui
était situé dans le sud d'abidjan il ya
eu un attentat terroriste inédit le
sénégal a un sujet bref l'ensemble de la
région aujourd'hui gangrené par le
djihadisme terrorisme marc-antoine de
montclos c'est le récit dominons
effectivement dit que si la france
n'était pas intervenu en 2013 les
djihadistes venus du nord qui est
surtout des touareg à l'époque qui
seront détestés à bamako une ville d'un
million d'habitants est la plus grosse
ville au nord en fait cent mille ha au
mieux avec tombouctou que cette
déferlante allait s'emparer du pouvoir à
bamako et sortent
il ya des discours officiels et puis on
va ni vous ni moi allons refaire
l'histoire
il faut rappeler que des ch s'est emparé
de mossoul en irak parce qu'ils avaient
soutient la population locale c'était
absolument pas le cas à bamako donc le
scénario qui est présenté comme une
évidence par l'elysée sur dans laquelle
sans nous finalement le mali serait
devenu un ca et listant bon
ça mérite d'être discutée qu'on soit
dans une situation de chaos si l'armée
française se retire il y aura des
situations de troupes dans le nord comme
il y en avait en 2012 mais encore une
fois pour beaucoup de maliens notamment
à bamako la situation s'est pas
forcément beaucoup améliorée parce que
la présence de l'état est toujours très
très très très faible est ce que
vraiment il s'agit toujours de groupes
djihadistes à dire qu'en fait on voit
s'entremêler énormément de conflit que
l'on qualifie de terroristes de
jihadistes dans certains cercles les
officiels mais qui en fait font
apparaître ou du banditisme armé qui
nécessite la plus tôt des opérations de
police des conflits bétail des conflits
d'accès aux ressources à la terre etc
tout ça est extrêmement complexe et
c'est pour ça que je dis dans mon livre
que finalement on a confié à l'armée
française une espèce de mission
impossible et je m'étonne un peu qu'on
discute aujourd'hui de savoir s'il faut
partir ou pas parce qu'un jour il faudra
bien partir quand même donc la question
du désengagement
c'est plutôt de savoir quand il commet à
mon avis mais on lui a confié finalement
la mission qui consisterait en fait à
construire des états au sel parce que là
il ya aussi un consensus pour dire que
le fond du problème que le djihadisme
c'est finalement le symptôme d'état fait
avec le fond du problème il est
politique et que la solution est entre
les mains des africains et pas de
l'elysée donc tant que vous avez des
armées nationales qui commettent des
exactions qui rackettent les populations
qui du coup deviennent très impopulaire
qui commet des exactions des exécutions
extrajudiciaires qui pousse du coup les
survivants dans les bras des djihadistes
pourraient chercher protection ou bien
de tous les groupes armés de la zone un
certain qualifié de djihadiste d'autres
de simplement de bandes armées
effectivement on a un vrai problème sur
le type de réponse militaire qui est
actuellement engagée par les armées
africaines et ses armées africaines et
c'est aussi un risque que le pointe
comme est donc des exactions qui vont
peut-être un jour rejaillir directement
sur l'armée française qui a équipé forme
aussi une partie de ses armées
africaines donc on a un vrai risque là y
compris je tiens quand même à leur
rappeler c'est qu'aucun de ces groupes
que l'on combat au sahel n'a jamais
commis d'attentats terroristes en europe
ou en amérique ne prenait pas du tout
dans la même rue lock on n'est pas
encore donc on eût dit il faut
intervenir parce que peut-être qu'un
jour il pourrait monter des attaques
outre-mer
couru comme il faut voir dans quelle
mesure la prophétie n'est pas auto
réalisatrice qui est effectivement à
force de combats de ces groupes qui dit
qu'un jour ils vont pas mobiliser les
diasporas africaines en europe pour
commettre des attentats à voir mais en
attendant je rappelle que c'est un
scénario fictif plaisanté oui c'est un
scénario fiction alors c'est ce qui se
fait ou bien tu rêves entier ce qui
s'est passé depuis quelques années avec
la syrie et les bancs et les banlieues
françaises sur ce point de vue c'est une
guerre préventive
certains endroits plus léger était comme
ça dont elle est présente je signale
qu'il ya des situations de chaos
terrible dans le sud du soudan dans
l'est de la rdc en somalie on y envoie
pas 5000 soldats dans ces tracés sont
pas les mains dans le diéri n'ya pas
d'hypocrisie sur le pour le consort
dessin chose est sûre son duo nantais
comme si on est là pour stabiliser d
étain et les aider à se reconstruire
très bien mais c'est lorsqu'il beaucoup
la mission des nations unies et pourquoi
faire intervenir la france or ce qui est
présenté régulièrement c'est que si on
ne fait rien on a respectivement une
déferlante djihadistes à la fois sur
bamako et pourquoi pas de nouveau demain
sur paris alors reprenons le scénario
n'est tout de même chose on n'ira qu'en
beauzire use les français ne voulaient
pas y aller
les politiques feraient des cas doit
nicolas sarkozy et est évidemment contre
une nouvelle intervention
ce sont les événements qui ont précipité
la france au sel aucun expert ne
souhaitais je vous rappelle qu'on
sortait d'aghanistan on disait après
d'afghanistan plus aucun soldat au sol
nofoot underground c'était l'expression
américaine con qu'on aime bien
on aime bien recyclés donc en fait la
france est allée contre son gré au mali
effectivement les aujourd'hui les
raisons pour lesquelles la france y
reste et hyper je vous rappelle que la
france est le seul pays au monde à
accepter que ces soldats meurent au mali
pour la sécurité est effectivement pour
les buts de guerre qui sont affirmés à
savoir éviter qu'il se crée un no man's
land jihadistes dans ces zones dont je
vous rappelle la l'immensité l'europe en
anglais c'est l'europe en quelque sorte
deuxièmement permettre aux africains un
jour de prendre à leur compte cette
menace aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas encore
traitées par eux mêmes ça ce sont les
deux les deux phénomènes et évidemment
par ricochet c'est de permettre à ces
états de se stabiliser de se
reconstruire et ça effectivement c'est
une autre guerre il faut savoir de
quelle guerre on parle ici
la guerre militaire ça c'est cette
mission est ensuite effectivement il ya
d'autres guerres qui viennent se greffer
sur cette opération et qui évidemment
rendre complexe l'équation et cc autre
guerre politique de développement
économique culturel mêmes qui
aujourd'hui effectivement sont à l'arrêt
et qui rendent la situation des
militaires complexes avant poursuit
pardonnez moi le débat je vous propose
d'écouter le général train quant à eux
qui étaient sur ce plateau le 26
novembre qui s'exprime justement lui
aussi en faveur de cette présence
militaire française et internationale
sur place
il faut continuer à combattre ces
groupes djihadistes parce que sinon ils
installent un état islamiste dans la
région et je rappelle que l'état
islamiste n'est pas vraiment la solution
qui a été choisie ni par le mali ni par
le burkina faso ni par le niger ni par
le tchad elle depuis cinq ans tout le
monde attend que le mali l'accord
d'alger par exemple soit appliqué
l'accord d'alger n'est pas appliquée oui
vu donc donc les populations évidemment
s'impatiente du fait que les accords ne
sont pas appliquées une solution n'est
pas trouvée et que des forces sont
obligés d'être présente forces
étrangères comme la force barkat forces
françaises où la minus ma force de l'onu
qui est présente également avec douze
mille hommes sur la région 1 sauf qu'on
n'est pas un petit peu seul là si les
états s'entendent et engage alors
emmanuel macron la vue j'appelle tous
les pays qui veulent nous rejoindre mon
sauf qu'il ya pas beaucoup de réponses
pour l'instant que peut faire la france
seule avec 220 soldats annoncé en plus
ce soir marche antoine l'ajusterons le
fait qu'on soit seul du côté des
occidentaux à intervenir des montres qui
est peut-être pas la même analyse qui
est fait chez nos alliés européens
d'abord y compris d'ailleurs les états
unis puisque rappelez vous quand on est
intervenue en janvier 2013 les plans
d'envol qui consistait à envoyer des
soldats au sol qui était pas du tout ce
qu'on avait en décembre 2000
douze avaient été disons de manière un
petit peu abrupte présentés comme de la
merde je cite susan rice qui était
l'ambassadrice des états unis à l'époque
aux nations unies et qui ne croyait pas
du tout à la capacité de la france en
tant qu'ancienne puissance coloniale à
rétablir la souveraineté du mali et à
stabiliser la région rebelle a vu les
1,7 et on a vu le résultat
sept ans après on voit le résultat
effectivement le mali n'a toujours pas
retrouvé sa souveraineté sur ce nouveau
projet elle est toujours qu'ils
perçoivent les impôts à la place de
l'état dans le nord les groupes
jihadistes n'ont pas désarmé alors qu'il
faut bannir donc réalisable mais pas
vrai qu'on va faire de grands axes étape
qui est né aux mille francs soit les
aussi à déterminer là dessus c'est à nos
amis européens n'avaient pas la même
vision non plus que nous de l'extension
de cette menace et du son caractère
global contrairement à ce qui se passe
encore une fois avec l'état islamique en
irak et en syrie où là il y en a une
vraie menace globale avec des
djihadistes qui viennent d'outre-mer
c'est pas le cas il n'y a pas de
financement d'armes ou de djihadistes
qui viennent d'outre-mer pour aller
soutenir la katiba du macina donc les
dynamiques sont d'abord locale et
excusez-moi si les allemands ou les
britanniques étaient vraiment convaincu
que si on ne fait rien dans la zone
demain ils auront un attentat à londres
ou à berlin joe garanties qui seraient
davantage à nos côtés donc voilà non ce
discours c'est un discours 2011 l'elysée
d'abord de hollande puis de macron mais
il faut le savoir tout le monde ne
partage pas ce point de vue sur
l'ampleur et la réalité de la globalité
de cette menace est encore une fois on
est dans une guerre préventive de ce
point de vue il n'y a pas encore eu
d'attac peut-être qui en a ras bien n'a
pas eu alors si on doit intervenir
partout dans le monde à chaque fois en
disant tiens il pourrait peut-être un
jour y avoir des répercussions sur notre
pays la séquence d'insuccès ce qu'on dit
et ce qu'a dit la susan rice et que vous
avez cités aujourd'hui les plans
d'intervention de l'opération services
sans fil dans les écoles de guerre
américaine
donc qu'ils y croyaient pas on l'a fait
et avec des moyens qui sont infiniti
infiniment bout beaucoup plus réduit que
coller leur ses premières choses
deuxième chose sur le djihadisme
évidemment qu'ils allaient financement
aujourd'hui 2
de ces katiba qui sont des financements
internationaux l'argent des ong dia
djihadistes du golfe arrive en en flots
dans cette région je suis content la
mena en revanche là où je suis d'accord
avec là où je suis d'accord c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de traces effectivement de de
traces évidentes de terroristes qui
viendraient de la zone de neige dont on
reste effectivement dans un djihad en
quelque sorte régionales bon ensuite la
france marque tels des points oui la
france m'a donné points aujourd'hui les
terroristes avaient l'habitude
d'attaquer en pick up aujourd'hui sont
en moto parce que il y en a plus on
estime aujourd'hui que marc khanne
depuis à peu près cet été a éliminé 150
200 200 djihadistes donc ces voix là on
fait le job
troisièmement les chefs qui sont
essentiellement arabes pour le coup et
qui sont pas qu'ils sont pas forcément
originaire de deux des régions qu'on se
bat aujourd'hui sont éliminés les uns
après les autres par par les forces
spéciales les derniers en date on peut
les citer c'est le numéro 2 par exemple
du gsm qui est un groupe qui se situe au
nord du mali il y en a un autre qui
s'appelle l'émir de tombouctou qui se
situe à l'ouest donc les résultats sont
là évidemment ce problème quand je
disais tout à l'heure a commencé à la
fin des années au début des années 60 au
début des années 60 c'est juste un
dessert l'indépendance du mali et à ce
moment là les anciens esclaves prennent
leur revanche sur leur seigneur c'est à
dire les gens du sud plutôt de pau noah
prennent leur revanche sur ce qui
historiquement les avait mis en
esclavage c'est dans les touareg et
depuis ce temps là on a d un
enchaînement de deux comment dirais-je
de révolte de rêve de révolte de
rebellions qui ont conduit au début des
années 2000 à la fin des années 2000 ah
au fait que ce que le nord tout le nord
du mali deviennent hors de contrôle un
espèce de far west dans lequel sont fins
et les djihadistes donc personne ne
prétend qu'on va régler les problèmes
même en ces temps ça me paraît assez
évident à mériadec raffray cela dit pour
vous comment vous expliquez vous avez
l'air tellement convaincus de ce bien
fondé de la présence française sur place
ce fort sentiment anti français
d'ailleurs inquiet cité ce soir par le
président français lui-même emmanuel
macron qui dénonce d'ailleurs des on
sait pas de qui parle d' des puissances
d'être ans
r pour discréditer la france pour
alimenter ce discours anti français il
existe on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur ce
plateau des observateurs qui disait la
france n'est là que pour l'uranium les
sacerdoce à cette info cet enfant-là
onmeda complètement fou on est d'accord
là où je suis d'accord avec mon voisin
c'est qu'en fait ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que les présidents
africains et africaines sont elles mêmes
confrontés un certain nombre de
problèmes qui sont des problèmes qui
sont liés aux eaux théréau à leur
territoire c'est les problèmes de
politiques des problèmes d'équilibré
sociaux des problèmes de comment
dirais-je de conflits ethniques des
problèmes religieux qui sont des
problèmes auxquels évidemment ils
doivent répondre
indépendamment ou en plus ou à côté ou
simultanément du fait qu'ils ont besoin
de barkan pour ne pas s'écrouler
complètement face à la menace est celle
là où on arrive parfois à des
distorsions discours j'ajoute quand même
pour être tout à fait complet qu'un
certain nombre de quelques quelques
responsables je citerai pas les noms sur
ce plateau sont connus pour des
accointances avec des groupes qui font
des trafics voire même qui sont en lien
eux-mêmes avec des djihadistes et qu'ils
ont évidemment aucun intérêt ce que la
sécurité revienne vous touillez ça et ça
donne le sentiment anti français
alors j'ai avant vous faire réagir
marc-antoine de montage on écoute le
sentiment que la classe politique
française qui est également comme vous
sur ce plateau divisés sur ce sujet le
mali sera t'il l'afghanistan de la
france sept ans après le début de son
intervention militaire va-t-elle
comprendre que la seule riposte armée
est une impasse son passé colonial et
les survivance de la françafrique
permettent d'en douter
la france a eu un rôle au mali mais n'a
pas vocation à rester indéfiniment ayons
un débat serein sur le sens et l'utilité
de notre présence militaire au mali et
préparons intelligemment les conditions
du départ futur de nos troupes
aujourd'hui à bamako une marche contre
la france où emmanuel macron est
représentée en hitler et les drapeaux
français sont brûlés un des défis au
mali c'est précisément le fait que
barkan est une opération militaire sans
objectif politique identifier les bases
de l'intervention française sont
confuses
en partant maintenant on créerait un
chaos au moins aussi grand que celui
qu'on prétend juguler nous n'avons pas
vocation à rester là éternellement sur
le continent nous ne sommes pas le
gendarme de l'afrique
nous ne sommes pas le gendarme de
l'afrique l'objectif politique non
identifié vous êtes d'accord la
canteraine de montclos avec cette
analyse très à gauche en tout cas non
identifiés ou non dit parce qu'il faut
voir qu'au nom de la lutte contre le
terrorisme la présence militaire
française s'est en fait à consolider des
régimes qui sont souvent très corrompu
et parfois même très autoritaire et que
donc la présence militaire française en
fête sert d'assurance vie à ces
gouvernements y compris contre le risque
de coup d'état par leurs propres forces
de sécurité parce que j'ai eu des
mutineries et puis il ya toute une
tradition de coup d'état dans la zone
on l'a vu d'ailleurs avec le dévoilement
officiel l'opération barkan dont
l'objectif a priori le mandat est de
lutter contre ce que les militaires
appellent les groupes armés terroristes
mais qui finalement quelque chose qui
peut suivant le temps variés et une
dénomination qui peut recouvrir beaucoup
de choses mais là encore l'année
dernière en fait l'opération barkan a
servi à rebours cdd des colonnes de
rebelles qui venaient de libye qui
n'était pas du tout jihadistes et qui
attaquait en fait le président deby qui
est faut-il le rappeler au pouvoir à
n'djamena depuis 1990 a lui-même étant
arrivée par un coup de force
donc évidemment pour ces régimes la la
lutte contre le terrorisme
et puis insister sur la dimension
globale de la menace si on fait rien et
c'est ça va empirer et puis ça va
devenir le sae l'instant c'est une
véritable aubaine
ça leur permet de se racheter sur la
scène internationale il ya plus de
critiques contre les violations des
droits de l'homme
ça leur permet d'obtenir des
financements une aide au développement
ça permet que la france finance les fins
de mois des salaires de la fonction
publique au tchad ce que peu de gens de
dunes savent j'ai écris ici public ces
publics
mais c'est aberrant moi c'est pas un
problème voyez as well as non voilà on
peut aussi bon voilà on débat justement
que l'on paie que l'on paye les salaires
de la fonction publique sans même poser
des questions sur la destination de la
rente pétrolière au tchad qui n'est
d'ailleurs même pas exploité par les
français parce que là au moins on est
d'accord à junas espérance mettra
intervenu pour mettre la main sur des
intérêts économiques
une idée très tôt n'a sonné rayon clair
les marchés sahélien en tout cas de
cette zone du sahel ce qu'on fait le
sahel c'est beaucoup plus vaste on
prétend en france mais ces marchés là
sont trop limitées chiens pour qu'ils
aient la moindre impact sur notre
balance commerciale
le seul intérêt stratégique c'est au
niger avec l'uranium dans le nord et
dans ce cas là c'est qu'il ya une
sérieuse erreur de gps en 2013 parce
qu'on est intervenu au mali et au niger
donc j'ai vu apparemment et enfin même
au niger les la france et part en pointe
dans le yari de montres sont les centres
aérés les numéro siret même pas dit ce
n'est pas non plus pas pour ça qu'on est
intervenue mais enfin on peut aussi
choisir de f1 ouais on peut aussi
choisir le modèle kadhafi c'est à dire
qu'on renverse et dictateurs qui ont
savent sans doute et vers le défaut mais
qui sont aussi capables de maintenir un
semblant d'ordre qui permet de ne pas
connaître le cas aujourd'hui donc c'est
bien
merci en tout cas monsieur marc antoine
pérouse de montclos mériadec raffray
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france après d'ailleurs ces annonces des
manuels mais kron ce soir de
renforcement de la coopération de la
france au sahel et c'est la fin de cette
édition se retrouve dans quelques
minutes pour 1 point complet sur
l'actualité
[Musique]
jean froid et loïc deux frères
aventuriers ont décidé de suivre le
cours du troisième plus grand fleuve du
monde
mais yang xi notre objectif est simple
aller à la rencontre d'un fleuve
mythique qui telle une artère irrigue le
pays le plus peuplé au monde
[Musique]
en cinq mois de sa source sur les hauts
plateaux tibétains à son embouchure à
shanghai ils ont parcouru plus de 7000
km à moto et en tricycle à la découverte
du lien qui unit l'homme à l'eau
[Musique]
nous filons à toute allure vers de
nouvelles rencontres et des paysages qui
sans aucun doute vont encore beaucoup
nous surprendre
[Musique]
votre lecture de juristes sur le système
japonais je peux dire que le système
judiciaire japonais est inique que dit
carlos ghosn hier dans sa conférence de
presse il explique qu'en réalité ses
avocats le japonais bien sûr ne pouvait
pas lui garantir un procès équitable
c'est dit est ce que cette affaire là
son évasion ne rend pas service quelque
part au japon
franchement j'y crois pas trop parce
qu'il ya quand même l'effet négatif
c'est à dire je dirais l'humiliation
mais quelque part le départ de carlos
ghosn
indiscutablement leur rend service parce
que cette hypothèque sur l'honneur d'une
justice consistant à ce qu'un procès
soit en réalité l'expression d'une
décision politique
quel déshonneur
[Musique]
des ogm c'est la cerise sur le gâteau de
la culture intensive et chimiques il
nous manque de technique pour faire des
ogm a explosé pendant les 15 dernières
années les ogm si tu as un outil sait-on
qu'il a il ne pourra rien faire contre
la finlande groupe puisqu'en fait la
faim dans le monde est une question
politique
alors ça c'est les ogm il ya également
le glyphosate alors le groupe 7 à usage
agricole
on pourrait s'en passer il ya des façons
de produire qui peut se passer de tout
terminer
des gens qui ont un intérêt à ce que ces
molécules hla soient pulvérisés sur les
champs ce que ça rapporte énormément
d'argent
peut-être que ça arrange l'industrie
qu'on parle que du glyphosate parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres herbicides
ils sont en jeu et le glyphosate et
d'une molécule qui est tombé dans le
domaine public la plus de problèmes dans
tout le monde peut en produire
il ya d'autres herbicides qui sont en
train d'arriver il ya beaucoup de choses
qui sont de l'ordre de l'économie qu'on
nous impose ces choses là
non pas parce qu'il ya un intérêt social
pascal intérêts économiques
[Musique]
je suis venu ici pour essayer de plonger
à la limite de mes capacités
l'énigme je n'aime pas le froid c'est un
défi en quelque sorte
essayez de plonger dans l'eau glacée
oh la vache
ce type qui a battu le record du monde
il a fait une autre plongée à 75 m je
dois plongé à 76 3 2 à départ
[Musique]
l'issue diplomatique est elle encore
possible en libye c'est en tout cas ce à
quoi s'attelle moscou sergueï lavrov a
reçu aujourd'hui les deux rivaux libyen
ali farah fta réveillait el harrach ce
dernier et celle du gouvernement reconnu
par l'onu a signé un document en
concrétisant le cessez le feu hier le
premier lui pour le temps d'y réfléchir
rappelons que ce cessez le feu doit
servir de prélude à une conférence
internationale sur la libye le 19
janvier en france le retrait provisoire
de la chp niveau comme annoncé par le
premier ministre edward fini pour le rap
à convaincre que les syndicalistes les
plus déterminés à poursuivre leur
mouvement de grève
les avocats aussi
contre la réforme ont été reçus
aujourd'hui par la ministre de la
justice qui s'est engagé à répondre dans
les plus brefs délais à leurs
préoccupations
un sommet à pau où emmanuel macron
réaffirme ses ambitions militaires au
sahel avec l'engagement de nouveaux
soldats dans la région pour combattre le
djihadisme les membres du g5 souhaitent
un soutien des états unis pour comme le
président français qui devrait négocier
avec donald trump
emmanuel macron en profite pour dénoncer
des puissances étrangères
il prône un discours anti français au
sahel
[Musique]
on vend soir à tous bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez en direct sur rt france
des progrès ont donc été notées sur la
crise en libye selon le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
qui a reçu aujourd'hui à moscou le chef
du gouvernement libyen a reconnu par
l'onu fayez à la âgées son rival rallye
faf tard l'homme fort de l'est libyen a
failli s hasard âge qui refuse de
rencontrer son rival a signé un accord
sur les modalités de cessez le feu entré
en vigueur hier un cessez le feu qui
intervient alors que la turquie a
déployé des hommes en soutien à ce
dernier des précisions d'antoine
claireaux après plus de six heures de
pourparlers le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
accompagné de son homologue turc mevlüt
çavusoglu se sont présentés face à la
presse est très rapidement se répondre à
aucune question ils ont fait état de
discussions très intense parfois tendues
entre toutes les parties présentes les
deux ministres ont déclaré que malgré
tout il était parvenu à la rédaction
d'un document final qui qui décrit les
contours de ce cessez le feu un document
signé par fayez elle sa rage le chef du
gouvernement d'union national libyen
mais pas par à l'ifa haftar l'homme fort
de l'est libyen je vous propose
d'écouter la déclaration du ministre
russe des affaires étrangères
or jamais dans mes gosses pas bah oui à
terme soit chaud
mesdames et messieurs nous tenons à vous
informer des progrès à temps à l'heure
actuelle chasse tient aujourd'hui
dès le matin des consultations intenses
avec vos parties digne n y avait plus si
un des ministres turcs et russes des
affaires étrangères et de la défense a
été examiné un document qui permettra de
concrétiser les questions liées au
régime au cessez le feu comme nos amis
libyens nous voulons dire ils ont
demandé un délai jusqu'à demain matin et
demain matin si le général athar signe
ce document comme suite de l'initiative
proposée par les
de prénom poutine et yoann nous
obtiendrons que sa rage et haftar
prennent des engagements nécessaires cce
se poursuivra et nous lançons le
processus politique dans le cadre des
efforts de la communauté internationale
et de l'onu ici run et même en jambes de
la jccisom après de l'année progresse
d'astronautes et les villes d'espagne
ans arrache le maréchal haftar au monde
on de l'armée nationale libyenne et
monsieur aguilar salah le représentant
de la chambre des élus de tobrouk
je donne une appréciation positive de ce
document et on se donne à l'idée d'avoir
un peu de ton supplémentaire jusqu'à
demain matin pour prendre une décision
finale quant à la signature de ce
document
j'espère que cette décision sera
positive
les représentants turcs et russes
continueront à aider les parties à
mettre en oeuvre les accords qui
constitue l'objectif des pourparlers à 4
luxe et chasser les doutes que les
gardois
les deux ministres ont souligné que si
elle parvenait à signer ce document
alors ce pourrait être le début de la
relance du processus politique en libye
quoi qu'il en soit le prochain rendez
vous d'importance et maintenant dimanche
prochain le 19 janvier à berlin avec la
conférence internationale convoquée par
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
entre temps la situation sur le terrain
et le respect du cessez-le-feu sera
observé de très près
elle élimine également au menu d'une
réunion entre le président turc recep
tayyip erdogan et le premier ministre
italien giuseppe compte et ankara
aujourd'hui elle les deux hommes
appellent à un cessez-le-feu durable et
ont souligné l'importance de mettre fin
à l' escalade de violence sur le terrain
q de moscow hader nous avons reçu de nos
amis des signes d'un bon résultat est là
à l'issue de la réunion de moscou
si dieu le veut
à partir de lundi avec ses résultats
il y aura un texte et nous irons à
berlin avec ce flex dieu le veut avec le
travail à berlin
nous organisons ce cessez le feu sur des
bases solides
inch'allah bourriche es salaam examinait
autres couches aux gens ce thème animaux
de l'udc est beau mon souhait est qu'un
cessez le feu est une base solide soit
la base de la paix pour l'avenir de nos
frères et soeurs libyens de nos amis
libyens
jean milbach du mln et toulouse rouge
est invité sur notre plateau claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales est revenu sur les
intérêts d'un accord avec la libye pour
la france et les autres pays européens
le président de la république française
a dit qu'il voulait que cessez le feu
soit ça cessez le feu durable et est
susceptible d'être contrôlé bon ça c'est
là pour la première étape pour le reste
il est clair que dans le passé il avait
déjà essayé de faire que monsieur sa
rage et le match à la star se
rencontrent ils s'étaient rencontrés
d'ailleurs à côté de paris
mais ce n'était pas encore mûr ce
n'était pas encore la bonne occasion je
crois aussi que les européens en tant
que tel ont des intérêts majeurs la
preuve le premier ministre le président
du conseil italien et à être en turquie
aujourd'hui pour discuter avec monsieur
erdogan est évidemment il ya derrière
tout ça aussi les intérêts pétroliers
qui ne sont pas étrangers d'ailleurs à
l'empressement de la turquie pour voler
au secours du gouvernement de tripoli
l'actualité en france avec toujours la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites qui se poursuit les syndicats
sont divisés après le retrait provisoire
de l'âge qui vaut certains restent
déterminés à poursuivre le mouvement de
contestation et appellent à de nouvelles
actions les 14 15 et 16 janvier
prochains
et précision en images
[Musique]
tous
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
a lyon les avocats ont manifesté ce
matin toujours contre cette réforme des
retraites
conséquence le procès de l'ex prêtre
bernard prennent a poursuivi pour
agression sexuelle sur mineur a été
reportée à demain et le désespoir au
cours de laquelle les avocats ont formé
res os avec leur code de procédure
pénale devant une salle d'audience du
tribunal
depuis la semaine dernière rien n'a
bougé pour comme le déplore xavier hôtes
un avocat et membre du collectif sos
retraites le gouvernement la semaine
dernière nous a déjà proposé rien du
vide du néant
il a réussi à mettre tous les bars ou
dans la rue il a réussi le gouvernement
à faire voter une grève part à
l'intégralité des 164 barreau français
c'est une victoire historique pour le
gouvernement jamais les avocats n'ont
été aussi unanime est aussi opposée à
quelques gouvernements que ce soit les
ordres des avocats existe en france
depuis sept à huit siècles ce que nous
proposent au gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'est la chose suivante il dit vous
allez vous retrouver dans un régime
universel vous serai à l'instar des
salariés des fonctionnaires qu'est ce
que ça change pour nous concrètement nos
cotisations retraite qui sont 14%
aujourd'hui vont passer à 28 elles vont
doubler nos cotisations est ce qu'on va
payer pour payer nos femmes et nos
droits à retraite notre minimum à nous
et à 1300 et des brouettes
il va passer à 1000 dire qu'on va payer
plus cher pour avoir moins de retraite
et pour perdre l'autonomie qu 1 des
corollaires de l'indépendance des
avocats rassemblement ce soir du côté de
la gare du nord à paris l'objectif
dénoncer la répression olic policière
sur la manifestation samedi dernier de
nombreux syndicalistes sont présents des
grévistes également et des personnalités
politiques écoutent et justement alexis
corbière esther benbassa ils étaient
tous les deux présents dont que ce soit
mais nous arrivons aujourd'hui une
situation telle que ça a été décrit est
proprement intolérable où on utilise
aujourd'hui des salariés pour frapper
d'autres salariés où on utilise leur dû
des fonctionnaires fonctionnaires et
pour quelle fonction peut-être deux ou
trois premièrement faire peur et faire
mal
sakho
dans la lutte bien moins de gens qui
vont aux manifestations on y va plus
avec ses hommes
on y voit plus comme avant quand on est
là j en fais gaffe parce que c'est
dangereux c'est objectivement dangereux
on espère a fait la liste des mains
arrachées des yeux éborgné on n'a jamais
vu ça jamais dans l'histoire du
mouvement social français il ya eu
autant de blessés que ce qu'il ya eu
encore des gis les jeunes jamais il n'y
a eu autant de gens blessés que depuis
ce qui se passe depuis le début d'une
formidable grève et ben moi j'ai suivi
pendant presque 48 semaines le gilet
jaune et jamais vu des jambes blesser
des gens éborgné des gens mutilés et
cette fois lisse il faut l'encadrer
c'est vrai qu'elle est là pour nous
protéger et part pour nous réprimer et
aujourd'hui on lui donne des ordres pour
réprimer
parce que cette heure gouvernement qui
n'a pas de limites qui croient qu'avec
la répression il va mettre fin à nos
revendications
et face à ces accusations récurrentes de
violences policières le gouvernement
décide d'infléchir sa rhétorique en
appelant les forces de l'orde à
l'exemplarité avec un usa juste et
proportionnée de la force des
explications avec florian lambert le
gouvernement infléchi son discours face
aux nouvelles accusations de violences
policières
deux jours après avoir déjà rappelé les
forces de l'ordre alors déontologie le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner a tenu à évoquer le devoir
d'exemplarité et la notion d'éthique
lors de ses voeux à la police nationale
cet usage de la force doit être toujours
en toutes circonstances même face aux
insultes même face aux projectiles ou
coup à la brutalité proportionnée et
maîtrisée jamais excessif
encore moins gratuit il en va de
l'honneur de la police et du sens de sa
mission
on ne laisse même si l'exécutif réfute
toujours le terme de violences
policières
christophe castaner a également souligné
l'obligation du port du numéro
d'identification 10 et rio
ces rappels adressée aux fonctionnaires
interviennent après plusieurs images
captées lors des récentes manifestations
des images qui ont provoqué une nouvelle
vague d'indignation contre les violences
policières
c'est dans ce contexte tendu que cédric
joue via a trouvé la mort dimanche 5
janvier deux jours après une
interpellation musclée autopsie de ce
père de famille de 42 ans révèle qu'il a
été victime d'une asphyxie avec fracture
du larynx un rassemblement son hommage a
eu lieu dimanche à levallois perret le
mot d'ordre de ce rassemblement la fin
des violences policières demander s'ils
ont de la justice veut la justice
je veux que ça moyen de justice qu'on
les condamne
alors qu'on le retire les biens mal
acquis et qu'ils arrêtent de dormir
j'espère qu'ils vont royal tout cela
arrêtez de dormir parce que moi je vous
empêchez temps le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner n'a pas
tardé à réagir à cet événement tragique
en prenant le soin de ne pas évoquer une
éventuelle violences policières
je fais confiance à la justice et aux
enquêteurs pour faire la lumière sur les
circonstances exactes du décès ces
résultats des autopsies soulève des
questions légitimes auxquelles des
réponses devront être apportées en toute
transparence en août dernier emmanuel
macron avait concédé l'existence de
blessure inacceptables concernant
certains manifestants
ce lundi deux nouvelles enquêtes ont été
ouvertes à paris pour des faits présumés
de violences policières
suite à la manifestation du 9 janvier
contre la réforme des retraites au
sommet de pau emmanuel macron rck larié
fille l'alliance anti djihadistes avec
ses homologues du g5 il annonce un
maintien des troupes françaises de
l'opération barkan sur le terrain avec à
l'engagement supplémentaire de 220
soldats et même écran qui souhaitent
combattre le djihadisme et soulager les
pays du sahel dans des frontières
spécifiques notamment au mali au niger
et au burkina faso
et quant à eux les présidents des pays
du sahel il souhaite un renfort des
états unis tout comme emmanuel macron
qui prévoit de négocier avec donald
trump ce dernier qui a annoncé sa
volonté de retirer ses troupes de la
région
le président français a par ailleurs
dénoncé des puissances étrangères qui
alimenté selon lui le discours anti
français dans la région travaille avec
nos amis journée le choix la décision la
demande des états souverains pour
préserver leur souveraineté de faire
appel à des amis à des alliés pour
combattre justement ces groupes armés
terroristes qui sont aujourd'hui une
menace avérée à la souveraineté de
chacun des états où il opère et
aujourd'hui à travers la déclaration que
nous adoptons les chefs d'état du g5 sel
ont exprimé leur souhait de la poursuite
de l'engagement militaire de la france à
travers barkan de nos forces
d'engagement de la présence européenne
et de tous les alliés dans le cadre de
cette coalition
pour atteindre cet objectif nous
changeons la méthode en mettant en place
une coalition militaire avec un
commandement conjoint entre la force
barkan et la force conjointe du g5 celle
en concentrant nos efforts sur cette
zone est donc en intégrant nos forces de
renseignement nos forces militaires sur
cette zone avec une latitude
d'engagement beaucoup plus forte au delà
de cela
d'ores et déjà fort de notre convergence
avec les homologues sahélien j'ai décidé
d'engager des capacités de combat
supplémentaires 220 militaires pour
amorcer cette dynamique viendront
gonfler les troupes dans est déjà
présente sur le terrain de barkan tous
les pays partenaires qui le souhaitent
sont les bienvenus pour rejoindre cette
dynamique
mais en marge de ce sommet un
rassemblement contre la présence
française dans le sel
une cinquantaine de manifestants
représentant les pays de la région et
même au delà ont manifesté le réclame
elle le départ des soldats français de
tout le continent la liberté est une
vraie souveraineté les manifestants qui
se comptent de nombreux slogans à
l'encontre du système français
un système de pouvoir selon eux
corrompus comme au temps du colonialisme
et pour marc antoine pérouse de montclos
écrivain chargé de recherches après sept
ans de présence sur le terrain le
retrait des troupes françaises devrait
être envisagé tandis que pour mériadec
raffray associations elle est
journaliste spécialisée défense
l'efficacité de la france doit être
souligné ça fait maintenant sept ans que
la france s'est engagée d'abord au mali
puis dans les pays voisins
ces temps de réflexion pourquoi les
groupes jihadistes sont toujours
présents le mali toujours coupée en deux
donc il ya une espèce de frustration qui
en fait est à la mesure de l'enlisement
des troupes françaises dans la région
qu'on soit dans une situation de chaos
si l'armée française se retire il y aura
des situations de troupes dans le nord
comme il y en avait en 2012 mais encore
une fois pour beaucoup de maliens
notamment à bamako la situation s'est
pas forcément beaucoup améliorée parce
que la présence de l'état est toujours
très très très très faible est ce que
vraiment il s'agit toujours de groupes
djihadistes à dire qu'en fait on voit
s'entremêler énormément de conflit que
l'on qualifie de terroristes de
jihadistes dans certains cercles
officiels mais qui en fait font
apparaître ou du banditisme armé qui
nécessite la plus tôt des opérations de
police des conflits de bétail des
conflits d'accès aux ressources à la
terre etc
tout ça est extrêmement complexe
aujourd'hui on voit bien que cette ce
cancer djihadistes les métastases
djihadistes qui gangrènent aujourd'hui
le sel s'étendent au bénin où l'avion
mais avec l'opération pour délivrer nos
otages qui avait été pris dans les
forêts du nord du bénin
plus tôt en 2016 à grand bassam qui
était situé dans le sud d'abidjan et
gallienne attentats terroristes inédit
le sénégal a un sujet bref l'ensemble de
la région aujourd'hui quand gagné par le
djihadisme terroriste
oui la france marque des points
aujourd'hui les terroristes
avait l'habitude d'attaquer en pick up
aujourd'hui sont en moto parce que il y
en a plus on estime aujourd'hui que
barkan depuis à peu près cet été a
éliminé 150-200 de son djihadistes donc
ces voix là on fait le job en guinée de
nouvelles manifestations ont eu lieu
contre un projet de nouvelle
constitution le point sur la situation
avec quentin mauclair la tension monte à
conakry depuis près de trois mois
maintenant les manifestations se
multiplient dans la capitale guinéenne
la cause de ces protestations un projet
de nouvelle constitution
lancé par le président alpha condé j'ai
engagé le processus d'élaboration d'une
nouvelle constitution tirant les leçons
de notre passé politique et
institutionnelle et en permettant à
notre nation de faire face aux défis des
temps présents et futurs
ce projet fera l'objet d'une large
vulgarisation avant son adoption par le
peuple souverain
j'ai instruit monsieur le ministre
d'état ministre de la justice garde des
sceaux et tous les autres départements
ministériels concernés d'organiser des
explications approfondies sur les
principales articulations du projet de
la nouvelle constitution cela doit
permettre à la population de
s'approprier le contenu et de se
prononcer le jour venu pour ou contre en
toute connaissance de cause si le
président condé ne s'est pas exprimé sur
ses intentions personnelles concernant
la présidentielle prévue fin 2020
l'opposition menée par le front national
de défense de la constitution soupçonne
le chef d'état de vouloir briguer un
troisième mandat l'actuelle constitution
limitant à deux le nombre de mandats
présidentiels
ce nouveau projet a mis le feu aux
poudres les contestataires crient au
coup d'état institutionnel
c'est un chiffon 7e tension qu'on
propose au peuple souverain de guinée
fait rentrer les copains et les copines
dans le seul but de satisfaire les
desiderata
elle est la force un tueur du préfet de
ses complices à notre niveau nous
pensons que cette ut est tout simplement
de la diversion de la comédie nous
restons même le principe d'une nouvelle
constitution
donc partant de là quel que soit ce
qu'il mettra là dedans cela ne regarde
plus la nouvelle construction
on ne veut pas
nous avons certes une procédure illégale
une passion que c'est illégal
on ne va pas l'accompagner dans
l'illégalité ce lundi 13 février
le front national de défense de la
constitution a appelé les guinéens à se
mobiliser massivement et de manière
illimitée
un appel qui faisait craindre de
nouvelles violences le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs prévenu sa population dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche la plus gaie
qui veulent troubler et nier aux autres
guinéens exercice le gouvernement exerce
une violente répression contre les
manifestants depuis le début du
mouvement
un jeune protestataire est décédé lors
de la manifestation de ce lundi à l'aube
d'un agenda politique chargé avec des
législatives prévues le 16 février une
présidentielle à la fin de l'année et un
éventuel référendum
la communauté internationale redoute une
escalade dans un pays qui a connu par le
passé plusieurs manifestations durement
réprimées au moins 21 civils et un
gendarme ont déjà trouvé la mort depuis
la mi octobre
la situation est donc tendue à conakry
et pour rudy kaspi cofondateur de whip
la nouvelle afrique une agence de
placement de contenu les guinéens
réclament de meilleures conditions de
vie
qu'est-ce qu'ils se mobilisent contre
alpha condé est ce qu'ils se mobilisent
ce plan pour des meilleures conditions
de vie tu avais la démocratie ça ne se
mange pas ça ne se boit pas et dans
beaucoup de pays africains y compris en
guinée il dirait très bien mais ici le
faire sept mandats qu'ils les fassent
mais on veut que notre vie sociale
s'améliore on veut être en sécurité dans
le pays
on veut avoir accès à christ et tous les
jours et on veut un emploi digne de ce
nom dans tous ses promesses faramineuses
d'investissement et le problème c'est
qu'à pas condé pour la danse moyens il
dit je vais rester vous vu je veux faire
un troisième mandat mais il n'a pas les
résultats sociaux et économiques
espérées malgré des annonces de
croissance et c'est là où le bât blesse
a strasbourg lé indépendantistes
catalans qu'un esprit du monde a fait
son entrée au parlement européen
l'occasion pour lui de réaffirmer
l'indépendance de la catalogne car
l'esprit du monde pointe également du
doigt l'espagne qui réclame la levée de
son immunité parlementaire
il accuse ainsi madrid de ne plus
respecter l'état de droit de l'union
européenne notamment après
l'emprisonnement d'un dirigeant
indépendantiste et c'était sa réaction
monsieur youm kiraz doit être parmi nous
aujourd'hui car il a recueilli comme
nous plus d'un million de voix mais
malheureusement il y à un état membre de
l'union européenne l'espagne qui ne
respectent pas l'état de droit en europe
et nous sommes d'ici pour rappeler que
la cuisse catalan n'est pas une affaire
interne mais une affaire européenne
aujourd'hui que le nouveau gouvernement
prête serment un gouvernement de
coalition les socialistes ont dû
s'allier avec le parti de gauche
radicale podemos une première depuis
1975 pour obtenir la confiance des
députés
le chef de l'exécutif pedro sanchez a
passé un accord avec les
indépendantistes catalans s'attirant les
foudres de la droite radicale métier
drogba c'est une première depuis la fin
de la dictature franquiste il ya 45 ans
l'espagne aura à sa tête un gouvernement
de coalition
le chef de l'exécutif le socialiste
pedro sanchez a dû tendre la main aux
élus de podemos le parti de gauche
radicale sur 22 ministres cinq sont
issus de ce parti le leader de podemos
aura même droit au titre de quatrième
vice-président en charge des droits
sociaux malgré tout pedro sanchez promet
un gouvernement uni et son gouverneur
local
c'est un gouvernement pluraliste c'est
un gouvernement de coalition mais avec
un objectif ferme d'unités c'est un
gouvernement qui va se nourrir l'idée
plurielle mais qui va marcher dans une
seule direction a supprimé un regard non
adéquat les faits il s'agit du premier
gouvernement de coalition dans
l'histoire de notre démocratie
il devra suivre une nouvelle voie qui
servira également de référence pour
l'avenir et mettra la police espagnole
sur la même voie que la politique
européenne à l'égard des européens
mais ce gouvernement ne s'est pas mise
en place sans quelques compromis pour
être sûr d'avoir la confiance des
députés
pedro sanchez a ainsi négocié avec le
parti séparatiste catalan le rc en
échange de leurs votes il leur a promis
des discussions pour trouver une
solution au conflit politique en
catalogne ce qui a provoqué la colère
des membres de vox le parti de droite
radicale
ils ont appelé dimanche à une
manifestation contre le nouveau
gouvernement qu'il n'estime plus
légitime aujourd'hui comme dans toutes
les mairies d'espagne où nous voulions
être ici avec tous les peuples
convoqué par la plateforme l'espagne
existent pour revendiquer notre nation
revendiquer l'espagne revendiquer notre
souveraineté revendiquer notre
constitution et pour dire devant un
usurpateur illégitime du gouvernement du
peuple espagnol que nous sommes ici pour
dire haut et fort que nous ne resteront
pas passifs face à un gouvernement qui a
menti à tous les espagnols
des manifestants qui ont fait face à des
militants anti fascistes et des
partisans de l'indépendance catalane
nul doute que l'avenir de la catalogne
sera au coeur des débats en espagne dans
les prochaines semaines le nouveau
gouvernement nord-irlandais salué par le
premier ministre britannique boris
johnson
après trois années de paralysie
politique exceptionnel tout semble
rentrer dans l'ordre à belfast ce
week-end les unionistes et les
républicains ont trouvé un accord pour
l'instauration d'un nouveau gouvernement
un moment historique pour le peuple
d'irlande du nord selon boris johnson
dans un communiqué qui a rencontré le
premier ministre les eaux
varadkar pour marquer le rétablissement
des institutions monde seuls write about
c'était comme je lui dis ce qui est
formidable aujourd'hui c'est que les
politiciens en irlande du nord dit de
côté leurs différences sillage ont pris
les devants et ont fait preuve de
responsabilité et c'est une bonne chose
c'est la chose à faire et farine fait
c'est également l'occasion pour nous de
souligner la force avec laquelle le
soutien sont les dirigeants ici en
irlande du nord et l'ampleur du travail
que nous ferons soutenir le royaume uni
et notre pays tu as en deuxième
d'ailleurs a dit qin à xian a dit king
c'est la fin de cette édition prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
demain 7h du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée et ont su rt
france
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits échos positifs n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent la haine françois vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême du
cese est le matériau tous les témoins de
notre époque sont dans la grande
interview